ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA AT KANSAS
STATE BACKER OR JUST BRADFORD
CABRERA CORTESE DALLY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN LASER GUNS
ALLAH'S GROVE HERZBERG WAY SO
HER TADO JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED. LLEVA LA MON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF BOTH HANDS FOURTEEN
TINO ROSSI RUBIO INNER STERN
AMBERG QUAKE OWSKI WINNER WELL.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON. THIS
MORNING I SHOULD SAY BY SENATOR
ALAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
COM LOGGER. SENATOR AL.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD. ONE
YEAR AFTER THE TERRIBLE MURDER
OF GEORGE FLOYD. WE CONTINUE TO
BUILD ON THE CALLS FOR JUSTICE
CREATED BY THE PROTESTS. HAVE
SO MANY MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
AND MILLIONS MORE THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. WE PRAY FOR YOUR
INSPIRATION. AS WE MAKE THE
CHANGES IN OUR- WORKING IN OUR
LATE DAILY LIVES TO MAKE
JUSTICE REAL FOR ALL. WE ASK
FOR THE COURAGE TO CONTINUE THE
DIFFICULTWORK OF BECOMING
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALL THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY OVERLOOKED. MAY WE
SAY WITH ELLA BAKER AND MOTHER
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS. MOVEMENT
WE WHO BELIEVE IN FREEDOM
CANNOT REST UNTIL THE KILLING
F BLACK MEN BLACK MOTHERS
SIGNS IS IMPORTANT AS THE
KILLING OF WHITE MEN WHITE
MOTHER SIGNS. LOVING GOD WE
BELIEVE IN FREEDOM WE COMMIT TO
CONTINUING ON THIS JOURNEY OF
JUSTICE AND LOVE WE RELY ON
YOUR- ALIVE IN THE SPIRIT. LET
US SAY I MEANT. STRONG.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEAN READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL BE
TEAM RED MM IT'S ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING TO
MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
IF YOU HAVE A ITEM THAT YOU
WANT TO REMOVE FROM THE FILE.
TIME TO DO THAT. FINNER
HERTZBERG. YOU'RE BEING
RECOGNIZED YEAH I KNOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR AND
DISORGANIZED YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR MOTION
RESOLUTIONS I'D LIKE TO MOVE
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN WHICH IS
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY OUGHT TO
BE AN ACTIVE FILE. FOLLOWED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO THE
INACTIVE FILE DULY NOTED.
SENATOR PAT. SINNER BANDAGES
MIKE. THANK YOU MATT THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- CENTER SO I WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO NINETY THREE WHICH IS S.
BEFORE SIXTY OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND INTO THE END
ACTIVE FILE. THIS RECIPE FOR
SIXTY FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TO THE INACTIVE FILE DULY NOTED.
THE EARLIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO S. B. SIX
SO TWO. TO THE INACTIVE FILE
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MOVE
FIVE ITEM TWO FORTY FOUR SP
FIVE EIGHTEEN TO THE INACTIVE
FOR. THANK YOU WERE MOVING TO
S. B. SIX OH TWO AND SIX GRAND
SP FIVE EIGHTEEN TWO THEN AFTER
FILE THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AT THIS POINT. SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TO REMOVE SP EIGHT OH THREE
FILE ITEM THREE NINETEEN FROM
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR TO
THIRD READING. THANK YOU. SB
EIGHT OH THREE FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR THIRD READING
DULY NOTED. ANY OTHER ACTIONS
AT THIS TIME BY MEMBERS.
FORTINO YEAH I RISE TO REMOVE-
SP FOURTEEN OFFER SPECIAL
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. R. RIGHT THAT'S B.
FOURTEEN FROM SPECIAL CONSENT
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT DULY
NOTED. SENATOR UMBERG. I WOULD
ASK THAT WE MOVE SP THIRTY FOUR
A FIRE ALARM ONE SIXTEEN T. AN
ACTIVE FILE PLEASE. SP THIRTY
FOUR TO THE AN ACTIVE FILE TO
THE NOTE. MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
OTHER ACTIONS AT THE START
CENTER WAY SO. I'D LIKE TO MOVE
FOR LEAD IN ONE NINETY SEVEN SP
FIVE EIGHTY TO THE IMAC THE
FILE. MOVEMENT SP FIVE EIGHTY
TWO THEN AFTER FILE NOTE THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. THIS IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO. MOVE IN I DON'T.
ANYONE ELSE DESIRES OF THE
ACCIDENT REPORT YOU KNOW- MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO REMOVE- OR
MOVE SP SEVEN FORTY EIGHT- TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. J. MOVING SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT TO THEN ACT
INACTIVE FILE THROUGH INOTES.
MEMBERS ARE YOU DESIROUS OF
MOVING ANY MORE ITEMS UNDER
MOTIONS ARE REAL RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR DOT. YES I MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE SP THREE SEVENTY FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY. S. P. TWO
SIXTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
NINE AND SB. SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY
LIGHT AND NUMBER TWO TWENTY.
YOUR SECOND RESIDENCE PLEASE
THE SEVENTY S. P. TWO SIXTEEN
AN SP SEVEN SEVENTEEN TWO THEN
AFTER FILE. REALLY KNOW IT
THANK YOU. MEMBERS IS THERE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEASURES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AT THIS
TIME. BUT- MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE I DON'T
WANT MA'AM SIR TERRY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU NON MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY T ADDRESS
TODAY SO WE'RE GOING TO NEED
YOUR ATTENTION TO BE READY WHEN
YOUR ITEM IS CALLED FIRST ITEM
UP IS FILE ITEM FIFTEEN. BY
SENATOR CORTESE SP THREE EIGHT
THREE SENATOR CHANGER YOU
PREPARE. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES. THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- TODAY ARISE PRESENT
SP THREE EIGHTY THREE THE
JUVENILE DIVERSION ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SP THREE
THREE SIX EXPAND REHABILITATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH WHO
COMMIT NONVIOLENT FELONIES. BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO DIVERSION
PROGRAMS BY DOING THIS WE CAN
ASSURE THAT SPECIALIST
SOLUTIONS PROVIDE FOR YOUTH
INSTEAD OF A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH. REPORTER THE RESEARCH
ON ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR BRANDED
ON THE CONFIRM THE YOUTHFULNESS
MATTERS AND YOU SHOULD BE
TREATED. DIFFERENTLY THAN
ADULTS THAT'S P. THREE THREE
FOALS THIS RESEARCH BY MAKING
YOU CHARGED WITH FELONIES THAT
ARE NOT SERIOUS AND VIOLENT.
ELIGIBLE FOR INFORMAL
SUPERVISION. ADDITIONALLY SP
THREE THREE ENSURES THAT YOU.
ALLOW US TO SORT OF PROCESS FOR
SALE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE NOT
EXCLUDED. FROM RECEIVING
INFORMAL SUPERVISION- I URGE
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN IT'S A NINE MM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FACE. BECKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD MICROBIOTA HI CORTESE
I DALLY NO DODD HI TORONTO BY
ADMIN HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE
FIVE MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S. MAN
FIVE NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. NO A
SHOW OF UGH HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER
I STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE ASKING FIVE WINNER I WILL.
NOW. SURGERY PLEASE CALL UP TO
MEMBERS. FAITH. PORGES NO
GROWTH NO MELINDA'S. FIVE
THIRTY TWO NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON THE FILE I'M TWENTY THREE S.
B. SEVEN THREE FOUR BY SENATOR
WAY SO ARE YOU PREPARED. SEEMS
TO BE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR WAY SO AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT SIR WHAT SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS- THIS
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA
CITIES TO RENEGOTIATE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THE
DEBTS. ACCRUED THROUGH THROUGH
THEIR REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE RELIEF
TO UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES.
THAT PLEDGE PROPERTY TAXES TAIL
TAXES OR OTHER LOCAL REVENUE
SOURCES TO REPAYMENT THOSE
COMPOUNDING. AND DECADES OLD
OBLIGATIONS AS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORTERS
NOR POSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES DURING THE-
COMMITTEE PROCESS- IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL THAT'LL HELP- THE
CITY'S RENEGOTIATING. COUNTIES
COULD ENTER OR NOT ENTER IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO IT'S
COMPLETELY. ELECTIVE I REQUEST
AND I BOTH. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM. TWENTY THREE HEARING
C. NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I BASE I
BECKER. FIVE BARGES HI BRADFORD.
FIVE ZERO FIVE COURTESY. HI
DALLY. I DON FIVE TORONTO BY
ADMIN HI GLAZER HI CAN DOLLARS
HIGH GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO FIVE JONES
FIVE KM LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI LYNN MON I REQUIRE.
FIVE MELINDA'S FIVE MEN FIVE
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. I A
TELEPHONE I CAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN BYE AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WOKE HI. HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVE MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM THIRTY
FIVE CENTER ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED. I DO NOT SEE MISTER
ALLEN SO- MEMBERS IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE HAVE A
FULL AGENDA TODAY THAT MEMBERS
NEED TO BE PREPARED WHEN THEIR
BILLS ARE CALLED SENATOR ALAN
ARE YOU PREPARED. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN
AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
CINDERELLA FOR YOURS THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH EXPEDITED SEQUEL
REVIEW FOR GREEN TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND REQUIRE THE COURTS
RESOLVE RELATED SEQUEL LAWSUITS
WITHIN. TWO TO SEVENTY DAYS
THESE ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS AND BENEFICIAL TRANSIT
PROJECTS THAT- THAT WE NEED TO
GET ONLINE A VERY SIMILAR BUILT
TO LAST YEAR'S SB SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN IT PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT IT WAS
CONTINGENT ON ANOTHER BILL THAT
DID NOT. REACH THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THE SAME POLICY AGAIN AND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR RIVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SAYING ON
MOUNT SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I'M THIRTY FIVE.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
I HATE I BACKER. GORGEOUS HIGH
BRADFORD MICROBIOTA HI CORTESE
HI DALLY I DON. FIVE ZERO SEVEN
BY ADMIN. FIVE GLAZER HI
FRIENDS. BY GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOUR. I LIVE ALONE. MCGUIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE NEWMAN
FIVE NIELSEN. I PATROL BOAT.
FIVE PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO FIVE
ROTH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN HI NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER HI WELL I.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. BACKER HI. JONES LET
ALONE. MELINDA'S. R. THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FALL ITEM FORTY NINE
SENATOR ROTH ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT ITEM HE SEEMS TO BE
MA'AM SIR TERRY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
REVOKE HERBAL TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS SENATOR OFF. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES FOR MANY
OF CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS.
REAL PROPERTY IS THE ONLY ASSET
THAT THE HOMEOWNER CAN PASS ON
TO. THEIR ERRORS. IN CALIFORNIA
ONE WAY TO CONVEY PROPERTY
OWNERS THROUGH A WILL OR TRUST
BOTH OF WHICH REQUIRE COST
PROHIBITIVE PROBATE. FOR STATE
PLANNING ATTORNEY CONSULTATION.
ONE OF THE OTHER WAYS
PARTICULAR TO THOSE WITHOUT
RESOURCES IS THE REVOCABLE
TRANSFER ON DEATH DEED.
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED PROVIDES A MUCH MORE%
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
MECHANISM OTHER THAN PROBATE.
ANOTHER TOOL FOR THOSE FOR WHOM
IT WORKS OFTEN THOSE WITH
UNCOMPLICATED HOLDINGS AND
SIMPLY A HOME. THE REVOCABLE
TRANSFER ON DEATH DEED WAS
CREATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AB ONE
THIRTY NINE TO ALLOW OWNERS OF
REAL PROPERTY TO TRANSFER THEIR
PROPERTY UPON DEATH OUTSIDE OF
THIS PILOT PROGRAM HAS A SUN
STATE THAT HUNT SUNSET DATE
CURRENTLY OF JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AND THIS
BILL EXTENDS THAT DATE
SPECIFICALLY SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTEEN IS BASED OFF OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A REPORT.
COMPLETED BY THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION AND IF
ADOPTED WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
THIRTY TO ALLOW THE USE OF A
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED TO TRANSFER REAL PROPERTY
TO A PUBLIC ENTITY PRIVATE
NONPROFIT ENTITY OR TRUST.
STRENGTHEN TRANSFER AND
BENEFICIARY PROTECTIONS SUCH AS
REQUIRING THE DB SIGNED BY TWO
WITNESSES REQUIRING THE
BENEFICIARY GIVE NOTICE TO THE
TRANSFERS THERE IS WHEN THE
TRANSFER DYES. THAT ALLOW
COURTS THE DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE THE TRANSFERS INTENT
IF AN ISSUE ARISES SIMILAR TO
THE WAY THOSE ISSUES ARE DEALT
WITH WITH WILLS AND TRUSTS.
CONTINUING RESTRUCTURE THE
RULES THAT GOVERN THE
BENEFICIARIES LIABILITY FOR A
DECEASED TRANSFERS AND SECURE
DEBTS. GIVE THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION ADDITIONAL
TIME TO STUDY THE EFFICACY OF
THESE REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON
DEATH DEEDS EVALUATE THE
EFFECTS OF THESE NEW REFORMS
AND MAKE ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR THEIR
CONTINUATION OR- THEIR
TERMINATION AND MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING ON MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
I'M FORTY NINE. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA. HI AT KENS. FIVE
BABIES. I BACKER HI FORGES.
BRADFORD I CAN BUY A HI
PROTESTING HI DOLLY BY DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES FIVE KM LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR. BLUEMOUNTAIN
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN FIVE NEWMAN
FIVE NIELSEN FIVE A TROUBLE
BOTH I PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
FIVE STERN HI AMBERG ALL RIGHT
HI WHAT KIND OF SKI. HI WINNER
FIVE WELL. R. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS FOR
JEFF HI WILKE. HI. MEMBERSHIP
BUYS FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FALL ITEM FIFTY FOUR CENTER WHY
BECAUSE HE- PREPARED HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AND
ACTUALLY INTO BUSINESS CENTER
WHY BECAUSE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SPF THREE
FOUR SIX WILL PROTECT CONSUMER
PRIVACY BY REQUIRING THAT
CONSUMERS BE INFORMED AT THE
TIME OF THE PURCHASE IF THE
CAMERA IS INSTALLED INSIDE OF A
CAR. MOREOVER IT WILL PROHIBIT
VIDEO RECORDINGS MADE OF THE
INTERIOR OF THE CAR BY THEN AND
IN VEHICLE CAMERA FROM BEING
USED FOR ADVERTISING OR SOLD TO
THIRD PARTIES WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE CAMERAS
AROUND OUTSIDE THE CARS WITH
THESE FOR THE CAMERAS THAT ARE.
TO MY SURPRISE ARE INSTALLED ON
THE INSIDE THE CAR HE WAS
PRESENT WE SPENT A GREAT DEAL
OF TIME INSIDE OUR CARS AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING WHEN WE'RE
DRIVING WHETHER WE'RE COMMUTING
TO WORK RUNNING ERRANDS AND
PICKING UP OUR KIDS- REVEALS A
GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT. AND IT'S FOR THIS REASON
THAT THERE'S MANY FIRMS- TAKE
COMFORT THIS CAR RELATED DATA I
WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT BY
TWENTY THIRTY THESE DATA COULD
BE WORTH UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
DIFFERENT FOLKS THEY USE IS IN
CAPS IN VEHICLE. CAMERAS TO
MONITOR OUR KEYS TO GAUGE OUR
ATTENTIVENESS AND RECORD
SENSITIVE INFORMATION WHAT WE
COMMUTE TO WORK OR PICK UP OUR
CHILDREN WHICH ALLOWS THESE ARE
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO BUILD
DETAILED COMPOSITES ARE HABITS
AND LIKES- THEY CAN BE USED TO
TARGET US FOR ADVERTISING WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT OUR
GAZE WOULD BE WORTH SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS.
SO THIS IS A FAST DEVELOPING
PROBLEM WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IT'S
ONLY A FEW CARS AND ALL THAT
HAVE THESE INC IN VEHICLE
CAMERAS BUT IT'S COMING. TO AN
END IT'S ONLY GOING TO INCREASE
THE INVASIVENESS AS TECHNOLOGY
PROGRESSES SO BY PROHIBITING
THE VIDEOS RECORDINGS FOR MADE
INSIDE THE CAMERA INSIDE THE
VEHICLE FROM BEING USED FOR
ADVERTISING FOR BEING SOLD TO
THIRD PARTIES THIS BILL SB.
THREE FOUR SIX ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM AT A ROOT IN BEFORE CAN
BELOW ATTICA. WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE CARDEALERS TRYING TO.
ARTICULATE HOW THAT INFORMALITY
NOTICE IS GONNA BE DONE WHETHER
IT'S GONNA BE A STICKER ON IT
I'D LIKE TO- HANG AROUND THE
WINDOW OR IN THE IN THE- A
SEPARATE SHEET THAT COULD
INFORM THEM AND I'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM- BUT WITH
THAT I URGE AN EYEFUL OF. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. HERE IN CHINO MICROPHONES
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I BASE. BACKER HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. HI TODD HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. FIVE
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH FIVE
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES FIVE KM LONGER.
I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON BY
WIRE. I MELINDA'S FIVE MEN FIVE
NEWMAN FIVE NELSON. BY A SHOW
OF BOTH. I PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER.
HI STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW
SKI. FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI.
JONES I DON'T KNOW. MMHM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBER. FAITH.
NINE THIRTY PLEASE CALL THAT
FOR MEMBERS. FAITH. SENATOR
ROACH ROW BOAT WHAT PURPOSE.
PLEASE ANNOUNCE YOUR OIL CHANGE
WHICH ARE BOTH BY TODAY. A SHOW
OF BOTH I DON'T KNOW. JENNER
WILL MAKE HIS PRESIDENT I LIKE
TO CHANGE MY VOTE FROM HIGH TO
KNOW. WELL I DON'T KNOW. MANY
OTHER LAST MINUTE CHANGES-
HEARING NONE. R. THIRTY SIX NO
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM SIXTY BY SENATOR ALLEN I
SEE HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FOLLOWING SIXTY I MEAN. READ
I'M SORRY. SENATE BILL FOUR
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR ALAN
AND ACTUALLY DO THE COASTAL
RESOURCES. CENTER OUR- MEMBERS
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT-
WILL IMPROVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
COASTAL ACT. AND PROTECT
WETLANDS AND- STREAMS IN
FORESTED CETERA THAT BASICALLY
GIVES THEM-ENFORCEMENT POWER
TO ENFORCE THE COASTAL ACT
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT CENTER
ALKAN'S WORKED ON A FEW YEARS
AGO. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WITH MORE DETAIL BUT-
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IT'S
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY. SIX CURRENCY NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BAIT. HI BECKER FIVE
FOUR JUST NO BRADFORD OR I
COULD A- HI PROTESTING. HI
DALLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN. HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HIGH
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. I JONES I CAM AUGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON FIVE
MOBILEIRON. I MELINDA'S FIVE
MEN. HI NEWMAN. FIVE NIELSEN.
NO- TELEVOTE I PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO FIVE ROCK. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BERG
RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL LOOK. PICTURE PLEASE CALL
UP TO MEMBERS. DALLY WELK. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NOSE TO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM SIXTY NINE. SENATOR ALAN
AT YOU AGAIN. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ME PLEASE
READ SORRY SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR ALAN AN
ACT RELATING TO WORK FIRST
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CENTER
OUR BUSINESS YOU KNOW OUR
CREATIVE ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST
IN THE WORLD BUT KOBE NINETEEN
BROUGHT MUCH OF IT TO A
STANDSTILL. THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECT OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ARTS COUNCIL
TO ESTABLISH AN EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL FOLKS IN THE GOVERNMENT
LEVEL AND COMMUNITY NNPROFITS
TO EMPLOY CREATIVE WORKERS AND
THEIR OMMUNITIES AND ESTABLISH
A TRAINING PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPING MARKET MARKETABLE
SKILLS IN THE ARTS PRIORITISING
LOW INCOME UNEMPLOYED AND
DISADVANTAGED PERSONS.
BEGINNING THEIR CAREERS IN THE
CREATIVE ARTS IT'S- HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN IN THE
LABOR COMMITTEE AND I. RESPECT
PRICE FOR YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. IN
NINETEEN NINETY BANNED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS
FIVE BATES. NO BACKER FIVE FOUR
JUST. BRADFORD I KERR BIO FIVE
COURTESY FIVE DALLY I DON I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH HI HERTZBERG.
HI WAY SO. FIVE HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
I LABOR FIVE THE MON. I REQUIRE
HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN I
AM BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HUSKY
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI. SURGERY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS MELINDA'S. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE MILLS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
I'M SEVENTY TWO CENTERED IN
DOLLARS ARE YOU PREPARED ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION CENTER GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SP SIX
SEVENTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES THE
COMPLETION OF A CLEAN FREE
QUARTER EFFICIENCY ASSESSMENT
TO HELP PLAN THE FUTURE OF
CLEAN FREE ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
FREED IS THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY MOVING
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GOODS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EACH YEAR
AND EMPLOYING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION. AND
WAREHOUSING SECTORS- SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE TACKLES THIS ISSUE
BY REQUIRING THE CTC THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER RELEVANT
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP. THE COURT
ORDERS THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF. IN NINETEEN NINETY
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON VOLUME SEVENTY TWO.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS I
BASE HI BECKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A DAUGHTER HI
PROTESTING. FIVE DALLY. FIVE
DODD FIVE TORONTO BY ADMIN I
GLAZER HI CONDOLENCES HIGH
GROWTH. HI HERZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO. FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER FIVE LAYERED FIVE LLEVA
I LIVE ALONE. FIVE REQUIRE.
FIVE MELINDA'S FIVE MEN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE.
FIVE PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I WHAT KASKY
FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOT MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS THAT I'M GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT SO I'M GOING
TO SWITCH OUT WITH. SENATOR
LIVE A- ALLOW HER TO ASIDE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE SENATOR BRADFORD
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
EXCUSE ME MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AN ACT RELATING TO BROADBAND.
CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE A
CONTINUATION OF LEGISLATION I
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN TO PROVIDE. A INTERNET
CONNECTION AND- BROADBAND FOR
FOLKS LIVING IN PUBLIC HOUSING-
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS NOT JUST A REUTERS IS
IN URBAN AREAS AS WELL THIS
ALLOWS FOR BROADBAND INTERNET
OPTION IN OURS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THING IN
HER MAN ALL EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX
SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE SENT
ABROAD FOR. THANK YOU. NOW
PRESIDENT I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A CRITICAL I DON'T.
CRITICAL I DON'T NOT ONLY TO
CALIFORNIA BUT TO AMERICA. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT THE KIND OF
ROSS JUNIOR POLICE TO
CERTIFICATION ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS BILLS AUTHORED
JOINT AUTHORED BY MYSELF. AND
OUR PRESIDENT PRO TEM. MISS
ATKINS. AND IT'S A PRIORITY NOT
ONLY TO THE BLACK CAUCUS BUT
THE CALIFORNIA AND AMERICA AS
WELL. SENATORS YESTERDAY MARKED
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
BRUTALIZING YOU KILLING IN A
PUBLIC EXECUTION OF GEORGE
FLOYD. AND IT'S BEEN. IT'S A
YEAR SINCE WE WITNESS THE NINE
MINUTES AND TWENTY NINE CENTS A
SECOND A SYSTEMATIC RACISM AND
POLICE BRUTALITY IN FULL
DISPLAY. A FEW DAYS LATER MANY
OF US IN THIS CHAMBER STOOD
TOGETHER OUTSIDE THIS CAPITOL
IN HONOR OF FLOYD'S A LIVE
INVOLVED NOT TO BE COMPLICIT.
TO BE BOLD TO BE BRAVE AND PUSH
FOR MEANINGFUL. POLICE REFORM.
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THAT HAS
NOT HAPPENED YET. WHAT IS
CHANGED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS RECOGNIZE
A BLACK AMERICANS HAVE KNOWN
FOR CENTURIES THAT THEIR TWO
TYPES OF POLICING IN THIS
COUNTRY. THAT RACISM AND
SYSTEMATIC IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT RACISM IN POLICING HOW CAN
BE FATAL AND IS FATAL. IF
YOU'RE A PERSON OF COLOR.
MASSIVE PROTESTS RESHAPE OUR
CITIES IT MADE US TAKE A SECOND
LOOK AT HOW WE BOND AND OVERSEE
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS. AND WE
AS LEGISLATORS HAVE PASSED
SEVERAL WELL MEANING AN
EFFECTIVE POLICE REFORM BILLS.
HOWEVER THERE'S STILL MUCH TO
BE DONE. SINCE THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD. ALMOST A THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED. AND
THE REAL TRAGEDY IS THAT MOST
OF THEM ARE BLACK AND BROWN.
THEY HAVE BEEN SHOT. LEARNING
FROM THE POLICE. ONE IN TEN.
HAPPEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
AS I STATED THE MAJORITY OF
BLACK AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS NOT ME LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS BAD AT THEIR JOB. OR NOT.
SUFFICIENTLY JOURNEY. ONE
PORTRAIT SHOWS PLENTY OF
RESTRAINT WHEN IT COMES TO
DEALING WITH. ARMED WHITE MEN
IT'S NOT ABOUT TRAINING BECAUSE
THEY GETIT RIGHT 95% OF THE
TIME WHEN THE ENCOUNTER NOT
ONLY WHITE MEN WHITE MEN WITH
GUNS INDIVIDUALS LIKE JEFF
BRICKER NECKLACE NECKLACE. KILL
TWO DEPUTIES IN TEXAS THIS
MONTH. PETER MANAFORT- FOR THE
INTERNAL SEARCH FOR MISSING OF
MAY KIDNAPPED AND MURDERED
MULTIPLE INDIVIDUALS IN
MARYLAND BREAKING TRAVIS MET
MICHAEL WHO KILLED AHMAD
HARBORING SIMPLY BY DRUNK
DRIVING ROBERT LONG WHO
COMMITTED A VIOLENT SHOOTING
SPREE ASIAN WOMEN THIS YEAR IN
ATLANTA. RITTENHOUSE THE
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO SHOT
THREE PEOPLE AND KILLED ONE
WALKING DOWN THE STREET WITH
ASSAULT WEAPONS. AN OFFICER
SIMPLY WAVED AT HIM. CAN. KNOW
WHAT ALL THESE FOLKS OUT IN
COMMON THERE WERE WHITE MEN.
AND THEY WILL HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT. BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT VALUES THE LIVES OF
WHITE MEN WHO ARE ARMED MORE SO
THAN BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
FLEEING FROM POLICE RUNNING
FROM POLICE BECAUSE THEY FEAR
THE POLICE I DON'T HATE THE
POLICE. THE POLICE. BUT LIKE I
SAY BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
NOT AFFORDED TO SEE PATIENTS
NOR THE SAME RESTRAINT OR THE
SAME RESPECT AND REVERENCE FOR
LIFE. ROSS JUNIOR. I'LL JUST
GUARDADO'S DIJON KIZI STEP ON
CLARK JOHN MONTERROSA. NO
RESEAL BEIRNE MARIO GONZALEZ OR
NOTICE APRIL MORE T. JOHNSON
CORNELL NICOLAS PIMENTEL. AND
RIGHT NOW FOSTER ARE JUST SOME
OF THE CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN KILLED BY POLICE IN THE
LAST SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AS
THEIR PARENTS AFTER LOVE ONCE.
THEY FILL. NONE OF WHOM WERE
ARMED. AND WHILE SOME OF THE
OFFICERS INVOLVED HAVE BEEN
CHARGED NONE OF BEING CONVICTED
OF MURDER. THIS TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY OFFICERS
HAVE BEEN CHARGED. WITH MURDER
OR MANSLAUGHTER. I SAID TO SAY
ONLY SEVEN WERE CONVICTED.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE THOSE
PERCENTAGE THOSE ODDS OF
GETTING THINGS RIGHT ALL THE
TIME. WHATEVER THE GEORGE FLOYD
WAS NOT RARE. WHAT IS RARE WAS
THAT THE MURDER MURDER ALSO
TRAWLING WITHOUT ACCOUNTABLE
THAT'S A RARITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN AMERICA WHEN
IT COMES TO. CHARGING AND
PROSECUTING POLICE OFFICERS.
PLEASE ACCOUNTABILITY. IS THE
MOST SERIOUS IN THE MOST
EGREGIOUS OFFENSE. AND IF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH THIS BILL THIS IS NOT ANTI
POLICE MEASURE BY NO STRETCH OF
THE IMAGINATION. THIS MEASURE
DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST IT
CREATES A STATEWIDE PROCESS TO
REVOKE THE CERTIFICATION OF AN
OFFICER AFTER THE CONVICTION OF
SERIOUS CRIMES OR TERMINATION
FROM EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
MISCONDUCT. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
THAT OFFICERS CAN COMMIT
MISCONDUCT IN ONE DEPARTMENT
AND SIMPLY MOVE TO ANOTHER.
THIS BILL IS NAMED AFTER
KENNETH ROSS JUNIOR. A YOUNG
MAN WHO GREW UP RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER FROM ME. IN THE CITY
OF GARDENA. THE OFFICER WHO
SHOT JENNIFER OFF JUNIOR. SOON
AS I HEARD IT I SAID THAT'S NOT
A GARDENA POLICE OFFICER THAT'S
NOT TO CHARACTER GARDENA POLICE
OFFICER BECAUSE I'VE LIVED IN
THAT CITY FOR FIFTY TWO YEARS
I'M ON PERSONAL FIRST NAME
BASIS WITH THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE OFFICE YOU'VE BEEN THERE
FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS. THE
LAST THREE POLICE CHIEFS I
PERSONALLY KNOW AND I JOKE WITH
MY NOON BEFORE THEY HAD STRIPES
LET ALONE BARS AND STARS IN
THEIR TOWN AND SOON AS I HEARD
I SAID THAT'S NOT THE CHARACTER
OF A GUARDIAN A POLICE OFFICER
ONLY TO FIND OUT THE PERSON WHO
SHOT MR OFF TRANSFERRED FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. AFTER BEING
INVOLVED IN THREE QUESTIONABLE
SHOOTINGS THERE. IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT OFFICES CAN
COMMIT MISCONDUCT IN.
DEPARTMENT AND SIMPLY MOVE MOVE
TO ANOTHER ONE. WITHOUT ANY
REPERCUSSIONS. THIS IS UNFAIR
TO COMMUNITY SPONSORED TO
VICTIMS OF POLICE ABUSE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY UNFAIR TO THE
MAJORITY OF POLICE OFFICERS.
WHO DO THEIR JOB EVERY DAY. BUY
THE BOOK. WHO PUT ON THAT
UNIFORM PIN ON THAT BADGE AND
DO IT IN ON A BULL IN A
RESPECTFUL. WAY AS I STATED.
THE MAJORITY OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN ON GARDENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARE PERSONAL FRIENDS
OF MINE. FIRST NAME BASIS WE
COACHED TOGETHER WE PLAY
TOGETHER. WE LAUGH TOGETHER AND
WE CRIED TOGETHER. CHARLIE
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY FOUR
STATES IN THE NATION. THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. FOR GETTING READY
GETTING RID OF BAD OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO REVOKE
THE CERTIFICATION AND LICENSE
THE BAD DOCTORS. LAWYERS EVEN
BAD BARBERS IN COST WITH ALL OF
THIS IT'S EASIER TO LOSE A
LICENSE FOR GIVING A BAD PERM
AND IT IS FOR KILLING UNARMED
MAN. BUT WE'RE UNABLE TO BE
CERTIFIED POLICE OFFICERS WE
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW VIOLATED
PUBLIC TRUST. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN CALIFORNIA A
STATE THAT PRIDES ITSELF ON
BEING THE FIRST PERSON
TECHNOLOGY PERSON ENVIRONMENT
PERSON A CHRONIC BLASTING
POLICE REFORM. EXACTLY THIS
BILL MAKES SEVERAL CHANGES TO
STRENGTHEN THE TOM BAIN CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT INSURANCE THE PEACE
OFFICERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
IN COURT FOR VIOLATING A
PERSON'S CIVIL RIGHTS.
FOLLOWING SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEEDED TO MAKE SOME MAJOR
CHANGES TO THE SECTION AND WE
MADE COMMITMENTS TO ADDRESS.
THOSE CONCERNS THAT MEMBERS
RATES AND I APPRECIATE THOSE
MEMBERS WHO LISTENED WITH OPEN
MINDS. IT HELPED US REACH THOSE
RESOLUTIONS. THIS WEEK WE MAKE
THOSE MAJOR AMENDMENTS- REMOVE
SECTIONS LAUREN THE STANDARD OF
INTENT. FOR BANE ACT CLAIMS AND
LIMITED WRONG THROUGH DEATH
CLAIMS TO EGREGIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS IS A MAJOR
COMPROMISE WERE ESTIMATE. BUT
WE CAN'T LET AS I SAY OFTEN
STAYED PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD. MEMBERS. WHETHER YOU
BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
THIS BILL WILL STILL ALLOW THE
ALONG FOR ABUSE. AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO SEEK JUSTICE REMOVE
THE MOST EGREGIOUS IMMUNITIES
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT CURRENTLY
UTILIZES THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
THE FUNDING POLICE OR
ABOLISHING POLICE. BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU. THE WHITE
INDIVIDUALS WERE BEING KILLED.
AT THIS RATE NOT ONLY WOULD YOU
BE ARGUED ABOUT THE
CERTIFICATION BUT YOU BE ARGUED
ABOUT THE FUNDING THEM AND
TAKING THEIR WEAPONS AWAY. IT'S
NOT ABOUT ANTI POLICE IN AT ALL
RATHER IT'S ABOUT ANTI BAD
POLICE. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
REMOVING THE BATH OFFICER IN
OUR STATE AND WE ALL KNOW THEY
EXIST. ARE COMMITTING SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT AND BREAKING THE
TRUST BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS ISN'T A
PERFECT BILL BY NO STRETCH OF
IMAGINATION. BUT THIS IS A BILL
THAT OUR COMMUNITY CAN TRUST
AND IS WORTHY OF MOVING
FORWARD. IT IS STILL A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE. AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS ME I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THE WORK. I ABSOLUTELY REMAKE A
MEDIC. TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. BUT WE CAN NOT
WAIT ON THIS ISSUE MEMBERS HOW
MANY MORE LIVES DO WE NEED TO
LOSE WE CANNOT ALLOW ANOTHER
YEAR TO PASS A LAW TO
COMMITTING MISCONDUCT AND NOT
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
CALIFORNIA'S DESERT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY CAN TRUST
AND WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY AND
BE ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY ABUSE
THAT TRUST WE CANNOT SHY AWAY
FROM THIS MOMENT WE MUST PASS
IS MEANINGFUL REFORM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS
WILL MOVE TO DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE START WITH SENATOR
ATKINS. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO AS A JOINT AUTHOR WITH THE
SENATOR FROM GARDENA. NINE TWO
NINE. THOSE THREE NUMBERS HAVE
TAKEN ON THEIR OWN HISTORIC AND
INFAMOUS MEETING THEY REPRESENT
THE LENGTH OF TIME AS WE ALL
HAVE COME TO KNOW THAT AN
OFFICER KNELT ON THE NECK OF
GEORGE FLOORED. MURDERING HIM
ONE YEAR AGO YESTERDAY. AFTER
GEORGE FLOYD'S MURDER MANY OF
US JOINED ON THE STEPS OF THIS
BUILDING TO PUBLICLY COMMIT TO
FIGHTING FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AND
TO ENSURING. THAT THE LAWS WE
CREATE HEARING CALIFORNIA
REFLECT THAT COMMITMENT. SOME
OF THE SMELL TO COMMEMORATE THE
TIME IT TOOK TO KILL GEORGE
FLOYD. SOME OF US PRAYED SOME
OF A SHARED PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SOME OF US JUST
LISTENED INTENTLY ON INCREASING
OUR OWN UNDERSTANDING OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM. ALL OF US
WALKED AWAY FROM THAT MOMENT
READY TO WORK. AND WE SPENT THE
LAST YEAR WORKING CLOSELY WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL CROSSES THE
FINISH LINE THIS YEAR. IT'S
TAKING COUNTLESS HOURS TO GET
S. B. TWO TO WHERE IT IS TODAY
AND AS THE AUTHOR ALSO SAID
THEY'RE STILL A GREAT DEAL OF
WORK TO BE DONE. WHAT A DEEPLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IT'S ALSO ONE
OF GREAT COMPLEXITY WITH MANY
MOVING PARTS. ONE THAT EVEN OUR
NATIONAL COUNTERPARTS IN
CONGRESS ARE GRAPPLING WITH IS
THEY WORK TO DELIVER MUCH
NEEDED REFORMS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE DELIVERING ON
THE PROMISES WE MADE TO EACH
OTHER AND TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
ON THE STEPS OF THE CAPITOL ONE
YEAR AGO. I LIKE YOU. BELIEVE
IN THOSE PROMISES AND IN THE
GREATER PROMISE OF OUR COUNTRY
AND OUR STATE. I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES ARE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR HIS SUPPORT
AND WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
AND ABOVE ALL I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA FOR HIS
TIRELESS DEDICATION ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION INTO THIS
VITAL ISSUE. AS WE DID WITH AB
THREE NINETY TWO THE SENATE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND IN FACT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO HELP THIS BILL
WHICH THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS
YEAR SENATORS ARE VERY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINSON- HERTZBERG. THE REST
OF. MY CAREER MY PHONE IS ON
YEAH YOU GOT IT YEAH THANK YOU.
THE MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY.
HE'S ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
BILLS WE WILL CONSIDER THIS
YEAR. WITHOUT QUESTION GLOBAL
PANDEMIC DROUGHT RAGING
WILDFIRES HORRIBLE ECONOMIC
IMPACT TO BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS THAT HAVE SO
DRAMATICALLY AFFECTED THE STATE.
FOLLOWED BY AN UNEXPECTED
SURPLUS. HAVE INFORMED OUR WORK
IN UNIMAGINABLE WAYS. BUT IT IS
THIS MEASURE IS IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IT IMPACTS THE SOUL OF
WHO WE ARE AND HOW WE TREAT
EACH OTHER IT HAS A DEEPER
MEANING. AS THE SENATOR FROM
GARDENA THE PRO TEM MENTIONED
IN THEIR REMARKS YESTERDAY
MARKED ONE YEAR SINCE THE
MURDER. GEORGE FLOYD ONE YEARS
SINCE THE HORRIFIC AN
UNBELIEVABLE ACTED THIS COUNTRY
IN EXTRAORDINARY MANNER THAT
AFFECTED ALL PARTS OF THIS
COUNTRY NOT JUST THE COASTAL'S
NOT JUST THE BLUE STATES WE
THOUGHT ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN TERMS OF SHEDDING LIGHT.
LIGHT THAT NOT EVERYBODY SAW
BUT LIKE THAT WAS NEEDED TO BE
SHED ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. POLICE REFORM IS
NECESSARY FOR THIS COUNTRY AND
SO MANY IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AGREE AND HAVE AGREED
WITH THAT. WE'RE AT A FLEXION
POINT. WHERE THE URGENCY OF THE
ISSUE CAN NO LONGER GO
UNADDRESSED AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED. WHERE THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS OF OUR
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS DEPEND UPON
OUR SWIFT. AND DECISIVE ACTION
TOWARD THAT END CENTER FROM
WHERE DATA AND ARE PRO TEM
JOINT AUTHOR PUT FORTH THIS
MEASURE THAT DEALS WITH AS I
SEE IT THREE ISSUES FIRST.
PUTTING GUARDRAILS AROUND
GOVERNMENTAL IMMUNITIES THAT
ARE TOO OFTEN USED TO SHED BAD
ACTORS FROM LIABILITY SECOND.
CREATES A PROCESS FOR
DECERTIFYING OFFICERS AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED TO HAVE BROKEN
THE LAW LIMITS DEMONSTRATED
THAT UNFIT FOR SERVICE NOT ONLY
IN THEIR OWN CURRENT
DEPARTMENTS BUT ANYONE KNOWN
FORSMAN AGENCY. FROM
DISCUSSIONS MANY DISCUSSIONS
I'VE HAD WITH MEMBERS THIS IS
AN AREA IS BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
THE PRO TEM MENTION STILL NEEDS
WORK. AND CERTAINLY YOU HEARD
THE AUTHOR A COMMIT TO THAT AS
HE DID WITH RESPECT TO THE
HUNDREDS OF HOURS HE PUT INTO
THIS MAJOR HERE THAT'S BEFORE
US ON THIS FLOOR TODAY. THIRD
AND FINALLY. WHICH IS REALLY
THE CORE OF THE SUBJECT OF THE
DISCUSSION- JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ON THE CHANGES BEING BEING MADE
TO THE BANE ACT NAMED AFTER MY
DEAR FRIEND TOM BAIN WHO SERVE
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT I CURRENTLY SERVE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
BAND ACT WAS ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED FOR HATE CRIMES. IT'S
BEEN EXPANDED OVER THE YEARS
AND THE AUTHOR. AMENDS THIS IS
A RESULT OF- THE DISCUSSONS
THAT WE'VE HAD TO REALLY FOCUS
ON WHERE OFFICERS ARE REALLY
BAD ACTORS WHERE THERE'S BARELY
BEEN A STANDARD WHERE THEY'VE
BEEN PROVEN TO BE BAD ACTORS
AND NOT TO HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT. ON GOOD POLICE OFFICERS
ARE NOT TO HAVE A HORRIBLE
IMPACT ON THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT COULD BE IMPACTED
THEIR TREASURIES TO BE IMPACTED
THAT REGARDS. BY SETTING A
STANDARD THAT ONLY ISN'T OVER
BROAD AND THAT ONLY DEALS WITH
THOSE THAT REALLY DESERVE TO BE
SUBJECT TO. CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
VIOLATIONS OF COURSE THIS
EXTENDS IN WRONGFUL DEATH CASES
EXTENDS THESE ACTIONS TO STATE
COURTS WAS DRAMATICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE LEGAL BAR. AND
ALSO OF COURSE GIVES PUNITIVE
DAMAGES AND ATTORNEY'S FEES
WHICH ARE TREMENDOUS INCENTIVES
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT OFFICERS
ENGAGE IN APPROPRIATE CONDUCT.
YOU KNOW WHAT. THE ON AS WITH
ANY MONUMENTAL POLICY EFFORT
THE ISSUES ADDRESSED IN THIS
MEASURE SB TWO WILL CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE ATTENTION AS I
SUGGESTED AND THERE'S MORE WORK
TO BE DONE BUT THE WORK BUT THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY GOES
EVEN FARTHER THAN THE FEDERAL
AND ITS FEDERAL ANALOGUE OF THE
GEORGE FLOYD JUSTICE AND
POLICING ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY.
WHICH RESTRICTS CERTAIN
POLICING PRACTICES AND ENHANCES
TRANSPARENCY AND DATA
COLLECTION BUT DOES NOT GO AS
FAR AS TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
AS THIS MEASURE DOES AND DOES
NOT GOES TO FAR AS TO PROVIDE
LEGAL REMEDIES FOR PLAINTIFFS
WHICH WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY
AND IS THE AUTHOR TALKED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA BEING THE FIRST IN
THE BEST THIS WILL MAKE IT. PUT
US IN THAT POSITION. THE
URGENCY OF THIS MOMENT CANNOT
BE UNDERSTOOD STATED AS I
SUGGESTED. MEANINGFUL ACTIONS
CANNOT BE DEFERRED. THE THREAT
TO JUSTICE CAN NO LONGER BE
IGNORED. TODAY IS THE DAY THAT
WE ALL MUST ACT AS AGENTS OF
PROGRESS. AND ADVANCE THE CAUSE
OF JUSTICE TODAY THE SENATE
MUST PASS THIS MEASURE I URGE
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP
TWO- AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM GARDENA- FOR HIS TENACITY-
IN MOVING THIS FORWARD AND
THANK YOU TO THE PROTONS- FOR
HELPING IN THAT EFFORT. THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT- PUBLIC TRUST
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITH RESPECT
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT- POLICING
ONLY WORKS IF THE PUBLIC HAS
CONFIDENCE. THAT POLICE
OFFICERS ARE QUALIFIED- AND
THAT'S IT AND IF THEY HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE POLICING ON OUR- DON'T HAVE
A TRACK RECORD OF ABUSING
PEOPLE IT SEEMS SO BASIC RIGHT
WE EXPECTED OF EVERY OTHER
PROFESSION THAT IF YOU GO AND
HIRE A LAWYER. OR YOU GO TO SEE
A DOCTOR- OR AS THE AUTHORS
STATED YOU GO TO GET A HAIR CUT
THAT THAT PERSON IS IN GOOD
STANDING AND HAS NOT ENGAGED
AND AGREED JUST BEHAVIOR THAT
WOULD MAKE YOU NOT WANT TO GO
TO THAT PERSON. I KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY A FEW
STATES IN THIS COUNTRY IT'S
ACTUALLY EMBARRASSING THAT WE
HAVE CONSERVATIVE SOUTHERN
STATES THAT HAVE THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS SEES FOR
POLICE OFFICERS WHO SHOULD NOT
BE POLICE OFFICERS. I KNOW HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE DON'T. AN
OFFICE CAN REACH IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN INVESTIGATION AND GO GET
HIRED SOMEWHERE ELSE. THAT IS
EXACTLY HOW YOU UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN POLICING. THAT'S
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING SO THIS IS LONG
OVERDUE. AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FORWARD LOOKING
REFORMS. TO IMPROVE POLICING.
AND TO INCREASE COMMUNITY TRUST
IN POLICING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHAT I TALKED ABOUT THIS
COMMITTEE I AM. ONE OF THE
MEMBERS PROBABLY ONE OF THE FEW
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE-
THERE ARE A FEW OF US WHO
ACTUALLY LITIGATED- HAS
LITIGATED THE BAN ACT. AND AS I
SAID IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THE BAN ACT- I THINK I USE THE
PHRASE IS A HOT MESS AND THANK
YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR. A OTHER
COLLEAGUES OF DR THAT PHRASE
BECAUSE IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE
THIS IS A MASS OF A STATUTE- IT
DOESN'T SERVE ANYONE WELL- AND
SO THE CHANGES. THAT ARE WITH
THAT WE HOPEFULLY WILL BE
PASSING TODAY WELL NOT PERFECT.
WE'LL BE AN IMPROVEMENT IN
TERMS OF IN HELPING PEOPLE-
RECOVER DAMAGES WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN. TERRIBLY WRONG SO
COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN I HEARD TONIGHT THOUGH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I TOO WANT TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO AND I WANT TO THANK AS WELL
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK ALONG WITH MANY
OF THE ADVOCATES THAT HE'S- A
BUILT THE COALITION WITH-
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAS BEEN SAID
BEFORE IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SAY
DECERTIFICATION IS WHERE WE
NEED TO STOP IN AND START AND
END- WE NEED TO DO MORE.
ESPECIALLY ON THE IMMUNITY
PIECE- THE GEORGE FLOYD JUSTICE
AND POLICING ACT BEING
NEGOTIATED AS WE SPEAK AS WE
KNOW MAY NOT EVEN INCLUDE A
MUCH OF THOSE PROTECTIONS AS
BEEN MENTIONED BY OUR MAJORITY
LEADER. IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
PROTEST IN THE STREETS IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO LISTEN TO ADVOCATES
IT'S ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO SAY
YES WE DO SUPPORT THIS AND WE
WANT TO SEE THIS STRONG-
FORWARD THINKING.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENFORCEMENT
ON OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH
THAT I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I WANT TO COMMEND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GUARDIAN- FOR
HIS DEDICATION AND RESILIENCE
ON THIS POLICY DATING BACK TO
LAST YEAR BEFORE MY TIME IN THE
SENATE. OF COURSE IT HAS BEEN
STATED ELOQUENTLY BY MY
COLLEAGUES THE HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE THAT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY HAS EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ATROCIOUS AND
UNFORGETTABLE AND WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. WE MUST
UNEQUIVOCALLY RECOGNIZE BLACK
LIVES MATTER. AND AS
LEGISLATORS WE ARE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO DO THAT. AND THE
CORRECT. OR BEGIN CORRECTING
OUR COUNTRY'S LEGACY OF RACISM.
HOLDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SENSELESS
VIOLENCE AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLOR IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT AND
NECESSARY TO PROGRESS. AND I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I. FULLY
SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN OUR POLICING.
AT THE SAME TIME I HAVE
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE SPELLING
OF EXPRESS THEM WITH THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA- THE
PROCESS OF THIS BILL TO ME IT
SEEMS PROBLEMATIC. THE BOARD
TICKETS CREATED THESE PEACE
OFFICERS STANDARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY ADVISORY BOARD
IS ONE THAT SHALL WE HAVE THE
POWER TO INITIATE ANY
INVESTIGATIONS INTO PEACE
OFFICERS. IT SHALL HAVE THE%
POWER TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE CERTIFICATION AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS SHALL BE
ACCEPTED UNLESS THERE WITHOUT A
REASONABLE BASIS. ALL THAT I
THINK IS WELL AND GOOD BUT THE
MAKEUP OF THE BOARD IS ONE
WHERE YOU STILL HAVE TWO OF THE
NINE MEMBERS. BE THOSE WHO
SHALL NOT BE FOR PEACE OFFICERS
WITH SUBSTANTIAL EXPERIENCE
WORKING AT NON PROFITS ARE
ACADEMICS RELATED TO ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS ON ISSUES RELATED
POLICE MISCONDUCT. TO
MEMBERSHIP IN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC NOT FORMER POLICE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ON ISSUES
RELATED TO POLICE MISCONDUCT.
TWO MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC NOT P. FORMER PEACE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BEEN SUBJECT
TO WRONGFUL USE OF FORCE LIKELY
TO CAUSE DEATH. OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY BY PEACE OFFICER
FOR SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS OF
A PERSON KILLED BY THE WRONGFUL
FORCE USE OF FORCE BY PEACE
OFFICER. AND ONE SHOULD BE AN
ATTORNEY. NOT A FORMER PEACE
OFFICER WITH SUBSTANTIAL
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
INVOLVING OVERSIGHT OF PEACE
OFFICERS. AT SEVEN OF THE NINE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD SHALL BE
PEOPLE. THAT AT LEAST ON FACE
VALUE. LOOK TO BE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD HAVE SOME KIND OF A
PREDISPOSITION TO. PERHAPS
BEING OPPOSED TO PLEASE. AND
FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
ATTORNEYS IN THIS ROOM. IF YOU
SAW A JURY MADE UP WITH THREE
QUARTERS OF THE MEMBERS HAVING
SOME KIND OF EXPERIENCE. IN
THEIR LIVES OR SOME KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE. THAT
MADE THEM PREDISPOSED AGAINST
THAT- I THINK YOU WOULD YOU
WOULD FIND THAT THAT WOULD BE A
PROBLEM AT A JURY- AND SO I DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE PROCESS.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT'S DOING
WHAT'S RIGHT AND PRETTY FAIR
PROCESS AND I ABSOLUTELY WANT
TO BE CLEAR I BELIEVE BLACK
LIVES MATTER. BUT I THINK AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE STATE TO
ADDRESS. THE NEEDS OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. AND WE HAVE TO
CREATE AN IDEAL FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL PROCESS FOR DEALING
WITH THAT POLICE OFFICERS. AND
I THINK THAT THIS PROCESS RIGHT
NOW IS WHAT NO I I'VE STAYED UP
ALL NIGHT I WAS HAVING A LOT OF
TROUBLE WITH THIS BILL. BECAUSE
I DO THINK IT IS FLAWED AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS PROCESS
ADDRESS. AT THE SAME TIME I
KNOW THAT THIS BILL. HE'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT SYMBOL
PARTICULARLY. GIVEN THAT IT
COMES ONE DAY AFTER THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE GEORGE FLOOD
KILLING. IT IS SYMBOLICALLY
IMPORTANT IT IS A. AS AS MIGHT
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES STATED
IT IS. IMPORTANT THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA LIED ON POLICE
REFORM. YEAH AND- YOU KNOW IT
IS I THINK. IT JUST SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR US TO TRY TO
PASS TODAY. I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT.
THIS BILL WHICH IS ALREADY AND
I WOULD COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA FOR TAKING A MAN
THAT'S REALLY THE MAIN ACT
ALREADY. I'M TOLD THIS BILL
WILL HAVE FURTHER AMENDMENTS
POTENTIALLY COMING AS IT GOES
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY- I WILL BE
VOTING I TODAY BUT I JUST
WANTED TO GLOSS MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL. AND TO KNOW
THAT WHEN IT COMES BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I MET RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY BOAT. THANK
YOU MR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER MAIN BASE IN
GERMANY WE HAVE THREE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE TO SPEAK WE'RE GONNA TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO CENTER LABOR.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CENTRE
TORONTO IN SENIOR SKINNER
CERTAINLY FOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP
TWO. I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR APART FROM GARDENA
FOR HIS STEADFAST WORK ON THIS-BILL. AS HE SAID THE BILL IS
NOT PERFECT. BUT THE ISSUE WAS
PERFECT AND THE ISSUE IS
RIGHTEOUS. I APPRECIATE THAT IF
THIS BILL GETS OFF THE FLOOR.
MORE WORK WILL BE DONE AND
SHOULD BE DONE. I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE CAN GET TO AN
AGREEMENT THAT IS BENEFICIAL TO
EVERYONE. AS A SOCIETY MEMBERS
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET BETTER AS
TIME GOES BY. AND I CAN THINK
OF NO BETTER ISSUE FOR US TO
GET BETTER ON THEM POLICE
REFORM MEMBERS I STAND STRONG
SUPPORT. AND I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU SENTOR LEYVA BASE
ENGINE IN THE SENATE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR ALSO THE
NEW SENATOR SKINNER THINNER
ALLEN CENTER- BURKE AND SENATOR
STERN. CENTER DRAWS A GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
I TOO WANT TO ADD MY VOICE AND
I THANK THE AUTHOR. I THANK OUR
PRO TEM I THANK OUR MAJORITY
LEADER. FOR THEIR WORDS. ADD MY
VOICE BECAUSE- ALTHOUGH POLICE
BRUTALITY. AND VIOLENCE ON
AFRICAN AMERICANS IS HISTORIC
AND DEEP. FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS
IN THIS COUNTRY. I WOULD SAY
THAT IN CALIFORNIA AT LEAST.
THE NUMBER NUMBER OF LATINOS
KILLED AT THE HANDS OF POLICE
IS ALSO SUBSTANTIAL AND
SIGNIFICANT AND WRONG. I TOO
HAD TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION
WITH MY SON AND HIS OLDER
BROTHER. ABOUT ABOUT WHAT TO
FEAR AND HOW TO ACT IF THEY
WERE STOPPED BY OFFICERS AFTER
RAISING HIM TO RESPECT AND
ADMIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT. FOR ME
THIS IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY. I
ASK YOUR I WROTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I THINK
WE'VE ALL HEARD. WHEN OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM GARDENA STOOD
UP AND PRESENTED THIS BILL WE
ALL HEARD THE PASSION. AND THE
FEAR. IN HIS VOICE. AND THAT
PASSION AND FEAR IS ROOTED IN
HIS PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. AND
THAT EXPERIENCE WHILE SOME OF
US AND ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US
WHO WERE BORN WHITE. HAVE NOT
HAD TO EXPERIENCE BENEFIT NOT
HAD TO GO THROUGH OUR DAILY
BUSINESS WITHOUT FEAR. IT IS
NOT ONE THAT WE CAN OR SHOULD
DISCOUNT IN ANY WAY. AND SO
WHILE SOME OF US MAY FEEL THAT
WELL YOU KNOW ARE WE GOING TO
EXTREMES ARE WE TRYING TO
CORRECT FOR SOMETHING THAT MAY
NOT BE. SO SIGNIFICANT.
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS SIGNIFICANT
AND IS A SIGNIFICANT ON ONLY A
SMALL PERCENT WERE NOT A SMALL
BUT RATHER A SEGMENT. OF OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND MYSELF
WE DO NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
THAT FEAR YES WE MAY ENCOUNTER
A DIFFICULT. EXPERIENCE WITH A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER BUT IN
THAT DIFFICULT EXPERIENCE WE
ARE NOT WORRYING ABOUT. BEING
KILLED. SO THAT BUT THE OTHER
REALITY THE OTHER REALITY IS
THAT IT IS A SMALL PERCENT OF
OFFICERS WHO. VIOLATE TEACHERS
BREAK THE LAW OR EVEN PULL
THEIR WEAPONS ARE SOMETIMES AN
OFFICER HAS TO PULL A WEAPON
FOR VERY LEGITIMATE REASONS BUT
IT IS STILL A SMALL PERCENTAGE.
AND WHAT THIS BILL. IS REALLY
GIVING US THE TOOLS TO DO. IS
TO BE ABLE AS OTHER COLLEAGUES
HAVE TALKED ABOUT. TO BE ABLE
TO ROOT OUT. THOSE OFFICERS
THAT HAVE A PROVEN. HISTORY OF
VIOLATING THE LAW. VIOLATING
PROCEDURES. FOR TAKING PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND VERY UNFORTUNATELY AS
CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR THE PREVIOUS FOUR
YEARS AND WHILE WE HAD MANY
BILLS AROUND THESE TYPES OF
SUBJECT AREAS. I HEARD HOURS OF
TESTIMONY FROM FAMILIES WHO
LOST LOVED ONES TO OFFICERS AND
ONCE THEY FINALLY WERE ABLE TO
GET RECORDS WHICH WE AS YOU
RECALL CALIFORNIA HAD A FORTY
YEAR BAN ON ANY PUBLIC RECORDS
SO WE COULD NOT FIND OUT.
WHETHER AN OFFICER HAD A PAST
HISTORY. OF HAVING- PULL THE
WEAPON OR READ VIOLENCE
AGAINST- A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS BUT ONCE THOSE
FAMILIES WERE ABLE TO GET THE
RECORDS THEY FOUND IN MANY
CASES NOT ALL THAT THE OFFICER
HAD A HISTORY OF THAT CONDUCT
THAT IT WAS THE THIRD OR FOURTH
DEATH AT THE HANDS OF THAT
OFFICER. THAT IS WHY WE NEED
THIS BILL AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO REFERENCED
WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW STATES
WHO DOES NOT HAVE A PROCESS FOR
DECERTIFICATION OF OFFICERS
THIS CORRECT STAFF. IT WILL NOT
BE USED WIDELY AND IT WILL NOT
BE USED WIDELY BECAUSE THERE IS
NOT THAT MANY OFFICERS WHO. WHO
DESERVE TO BE CERTIFIED BUT FOR
THOSE WHO DO WE NEED THIS TOOL
AND WITH THAT I ASK THE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER ALAN. MEMBERS
LET ME START BY THINKING ALL OF
THE SENATORS ARE WORKING HARD
ON THIS IMMENSELY IMPORTANT
BILL. HI THERE'S NO QUESTION IN
MY MIND THAT WE NEED TO PUT IN
PLACE PROCEDURES TO ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE JUST NOT PASSING
ALONG BAD COPS WHO ENGAGE IN
BAD BEHAVIOR AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION IN MY MIND IS IN AS
WELL. THAT THE MANY MANY OF THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO PUT ON THE UNIFORM THE
BATCH EVERY DAY TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. ARE GOOD PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND FOR WHOM- THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE DISHONORED THE POLICE
PROFESSION. REALLY A CAUSE
TREMENDOUS PAIN AND DAMAGE AND
IF ANYTHING. GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS IMPORTANTE
CERTIFICATION ISSUE IS GOING
TO. MAKE LIFE BETTER. FOR
THOSE- HONORABLE PEOPLE WHO.
WHO SERVE HONORABLY AS AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SO. I'M UP
FOR THAT MANY OTHER REASONS I'M
I'M IN SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S GETTING
OUT AND ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT.
PUBLIC POLICY CHALLENGE- THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS AS A
SOCIETY. ALL I WILL SAY- THE
PRETENDED MENTION THERE'S STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY A WORK IN PROGRESS
THIS BILL I WANT TO THINK OF
WHAT THE LETTERS THE LETTER OF
SENATORS WHO WORKED. HARD ON
GETTING INTO THIS PLACE SO FAR.
AND I DO JUST WANT TO. SAY THAT
I AM STRUCK BY THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CENTER- WHO WHO
SPOKE ABOUT. THE MAKEUP OF THE
BOARD I DO THINK IN THE END OF
THE DAY ON THIS WE NEED TO
CREATE A FAIRBOARD. WE ARE
GIVING THIS BOARD. A QUASI
JUDICIAL POWERS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SOME FOLKS WHO
TRY TO DIMINISH. THE POWERS BUT
IF YOU GO INTO THE- LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL AT THE- THE DECISIONS
OF THIS BOARD- REALLY ARE.
GOING TO BE VERY INFLUENTIAL AS
TO THE FINAL DECISION MAKING
PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH- POLICE
OFFICERS- A STATUS. IN THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE IT WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW. IT CERTAINLY SEEMS TO
SKEW. TOWARD FOLKS ARE GONNA BE
PRETTY SKEPTICAL OF- A POLICE
AND I KNOW THAT THE DEBATE.
THERE IS A LOT OF THE FOLKS WHO
REPRESENT THE POLICE WANTED TO
BE HALF POLICE AND HALF NOT
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M INTERESTED
IN. I MEASURED MORE IN A MODEL
AKIN TO. THE SORTS OF BOARDS
THAT WE HAVE THAT OVERSEE ALL
SORTS OF. OF A OF A PROFESSIONS
WHICH IS DOMINATED BY REGULAR
FOLKS CIVILIANS. WHO ARE NOT.
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT-
BUT- WHO ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO TREAT THESE ISSUES FAIRLY-
AND I KNOW THAT'S A DIFFICULT
BALANCE TO STRIKE. AND I FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT- THE AUTHOR AND
IN THE FOLKS AS THIS BILL MOVES
ALONG- AS IT GOES TO THE
ASSEMBLY IN AS THEY ENGAGE IN
NEGOTIATIONS. WITH EVERYBODY
INVOLVED THAT WE'LL GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THIS BOARD. IS
SOMETHING THAT IS FAIR- THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE A CLEAR
DECISIONS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
RESULT IN GETTING BAD COPS OFF
THE STREET. AND MAKING LIFE
BETTER FOR EVERYBODY. I IT IS
ABSOLUTELY INAPPROPRIATE FOR US
TO ENGAGE IN THE MARCH OF THE
LEMONS THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS
AMONG SOME OF OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WHERE- WHERE. I
HAVE SOME ERRANT OFFICERS
BASICALLY IT PASSED ON TO
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT AND THEN
THEY GO ON. AND REPEATING THE
SAME. BEHAVIOR HOW WE TO BREAK
THE CYCLE AND THAT'S I. PLEASED
THAT- THIS BILL MOVING FOR
LET'S THE BOARD IS. I. THIS
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATED
PROSECUTED AND CONVICTED. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OF
CORRUPTION AND OR ABUSE. OF
THEIR POWER- THIS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IS THIRTY THREE
PAGES YOU SHOULD READ IT. IS
THERE AN ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
THE CERTIFYING THOSE WHO ABUSE
THEIR POWER. ABSOLUTELY NOT IN
FACT THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING YOU LISTEN TO THE
LITANY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS WHO ALL SAID WE
SHOULD HAVE A PROCESS TO
DECERTIFY POLICE OFFICERS THOSE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ABUSE
THEIR POWER. THAT QUESTION I
THINK IT IS RESOLVED. THE OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN THESE ARE TOO
DISPARATE ISSUES ONE WAS THE
BANE ACT AND WHAT THE TRIGGERS
WOULD BE FOR A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL TO BE PERSONALLY
LIABLE IS THEY SHOULD BE AS
THEY SHOULD BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANY ABUSE. THE QUESTION WAS IS
TO THE TRIGGER AS SOME OF YOU
KNOW WHY I DIDN'T VOTE ON THE
BILL BECAUSE I WAS CONCERNED
IT'S NOT JUST THAT WE SHOULD
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AS WE
SHOULD. IT IS THAT WE SHOULD
ADDRESS IT IN A WAY. THAT FIXES
THE ISSUE AND DOESN'T SIMPLY
TURN OVER THE COURTS WAS THERE
IMPROVEMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
BANE ACT ABSOLUTELY THERE WAS
IMPROVEMENT. IS THERE STILL
AMBIGUITY THERE STILL AMBIGUITY
AS TO THE TERM CONSTITUTES A
CRIME OF VIOLENCE. SHOULD WE
FIX THAT WE SHOULD FIX THAT. IS
THERE AN ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
THE ADVISORY PANEL. THE PANEL
IS NOT JUST AN ADVISORY PANEL
IT SIMPLY GIVES RECOMMENDATIONS
THIS IS A REAL PANEL THAT HAS
AUTHORITY. THIS IS A REAL PANEL
THAT CAN. MAKE DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT MANY FOLKS LIVES. HAVE
THERE BEEN JURIES HAVE THERE
BEEN FACT FINDERS HISTORICALLY
THAT IT DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
THOSE. PERSONS OF COLOR
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY. IS THE
WAY TO FIX THAT PROBLEM TO SAY
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO SKEW IT IN ANOTHER
DIRECTION WE'RE GOING TO CREATE
THE PERCEPTION. IF NOT THE
REALITY. THAT THIS PANEL. IS
SKEWED TO CORRECT THE
INJUSTICES OF THE PAST. I THINK
NOT. I THINK THAT THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT IS THIS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE IS A STARGATE YOU
ABSOLUTELY IT'S HISTORIC ISSUE
THERE ARE ONLY A HANDFUL OF
VOTES THAT FOLKS LET ME
REMEMBER THOSE OF US WHO SERVE
WHETHER IT'S A TWELVE OR
HOWEVER MANY YEARS THERE'S ONLY
A HANDFUL OF VOTES AND THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT FOLKS REMEMBER
ABSOLUTELY IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
FOLKS REMEMBER. ANI GIVE CREDIT
TO MY COLLEAGUE ESPECIALLY FROM
GARDENA FOR ADVANCING THIS
ISSUE. BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT IN
A WAY THAT IS FAIR THAT IS
RIGHT. WE HAVE TO DO IT NO
WHERE A WAY. THAT THE COURTS
WON'T MANIPULATED. LIKE AS WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE BANE ACT.
SHOULD THIS PROCESS MOVE
FORWARD IT SHOULD IT SHOULD NOT
DIE TODAY. SHOULD GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY TYPICALLY ASSEMBLY SO
THAT IT CAN BE APPROVED IT
SHOULD. THEREFORE- BOWTIE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER-
BURKE CENTER SURE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT'S
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU- FIRST I
WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR- AS I DID DURING THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR NOT
JUST THE POLICY EDUCATION BUT
THE PERSONAL ID CATION- THEY'RE
NOT GOING THROUGH EXPERIENCING.
IT THROUGH HIS EYES- SOMETHING
THAT I CANNOT FEEL- WHAT IT IS
TO WALK AROUND ON THE STREETS.
AS A PERSON OF COLOR.
SPECIFICALLY AS A BLACK MAN.
AND THE YOUNG NOBLE FEAR. THAT
IS ASSOCIATE ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM BUT BECAUSE OF.
THE INADEQUACIES OF CALIFORNIA
LAW. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FIXING
HERE TODAY. WE WON'T FIX THE
WHOLE ISSUE. AND I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THAT. WE HAVE TO
GET THIS WORK DONE THIS YEAR.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
PASS THIS BILL TODAY. I ALSO
BELIEVE WE NEEDED THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I SHOULD
ADD THAT. THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGREE. I
HAVEN'T TALKED TO A SINGLE
PERSON. IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOESN'T AGREE THAT THERE OUGHT
TO BE AS DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS. BUT THE PEOPLE WHO.
HAD THEIR KIDS MURDERED. AND
STILL HAVE NO ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
NEED SOME JUSTICE. AND THE
RECYCLING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO. I FEEL A SENSE OF
IMPUNITY AND IMMUNITY HAS TO
END. SO I APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND THE GOOD FAITH SHOWN
ESPECIALLY IN OUR- OUR HARD
WORK ON THE DANE ACT ISSUES IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHORS. WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT
THESE ISSUES AND TO MOVE. BUT I
DON'T I DON'T APPRECIATE. AN
UNDERLYING RULE OF THUMB THAT
SEEMS TO HAVE EMERGED IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THAT SOMEHOW IT IS RACIST TO
ASK QUESTIONS. ESPECIALLY IF
YOU ARE WHITE. BUT SOMEHOW
DIGGING INTO DETAILS HERE AND
DOING THE WORK AS A SENATOR.
WAS A LEGISLATIVE BODY. SOMEHOW
NOT OUR PURVIEW. NO WE SHOULD
FEEL ASHAMED. ARE GUILTY OF
DIGGING IN. DETAILS MATTER.
GETTING THIS RIGHT MATTERS WE
WILL SET THE PACE FOR THIS
COUNTRY I HOPE THIS CONGRESS IS
WATCHING I HOPE THEY PASS THE
GEORGE FLOYD JUST POLICING ACT
AND I HOPE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD.
BUT IT IS UNFAIR AND IT IS.
UNBECOMING OF HIS BODY. TO
CASTIGATE OR DEMONISE
COLLEAGUES. BASED ON THEIR RACE.
WE'RE ALL ACTIVE HERE REPRESENT
OUR PEOPLE. AND I THINK THE
CRITICAL NATURE OF THE DEBATE
TODAY HERE AND GOING FORWARD.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT
MUST FIGHT FIERCELY TO PROTECT.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT SPACE ON
THIS LEGISLATION OR OTHER BILLS.
IF I DON'T HAVE EQUAL STANDING
TO ASK A QUESTION JUST LIKE
ANYBODY ELSE HERE. SOMETHING'S
WRONG. SO IN THAT SPIRIT I.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY. BUT THERE ARE
BIG REASON THE FCTORS THAT THE
COMMISSION WILL BE LOOKING TO.
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES APPOINTED
SOME OF THESE OUT. WHAT IS
CONDUCT THAT DOESN'T RESPECT
THE RIGHTS OF THE PUBLIC. WHAT
IS THE NOT A VIOLATION OF LAW
BUT SOME OTHER VIOLATION QUOTE
SOME OTHER VIOLATION. THAT
MIGHT LEAD TO SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. THE UNAUTHORIZED
USE OF FORCE INCLUDE NOT JUST
LEGAL FORCE OR ABUSIVE FORCE OR
PHYSICAL MISCONDUCT PUT. BUT A
MISTAKE FROM A DISPATCH
OPERATOR WHERE THERE'S A
MISTAKEN ARREST IN SOMEONE'S
HAND CUFF IS THAT IN ON
AUTHORIZE USE OF FORCE. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE GO
AFTER. THE WORST THE PEOPLE WHO
DISHONOR THIS PROFESSION. THERE
WERE NOT ALSO DETERRING YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM GOING OUT TO BE
GOOD OFFICERS BECAUSE WE STILL
NEED LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WHO
HAVE OWNERS WHO WANT TO SERVE.
I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT. THIS
TREND IN OUR POLITICS RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WE BROAD BRUSH. AND
OSTRACIZING DEMONIZES TOXIC I
THINK IT'S GONNA ROAD THE
FABRIC OF OUR DEMOCRACY IF
WE'RE NOT CAREFUL. SO I LOVE
THIS SENATE FOR ITS WORK. I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF A MAJORITY LEADER JUDICIARY
CHAIR THE CENTER FROM GARDENA.
BUT WITH THIS PHONE HERE TODAY
I HOPEWE COMMIT OURSELVES TO A
DEBATE IS GOING TO BE
RESPECTFUL. AND SUBSTANTIVE.
ALCIDE FORCES WILL DO IT THEY
MAKE COLLEAGUES BUT- WE OWE IT
TO EACH OTHER TO RESERVE SPACE.
TO BE THE CENTER IS THAT WE ARE.
SO WITH THAT OUT HI I WILL.
URGE THE AUTHOR GOING FORWARD.
TO HOLD ON TO THAT SPACE IN THE
COURAGE THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO DO THAT. TO GET THIS RIGHT.
IT'S PASSED THIS LAW THIS YEAR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN SEVERAL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I.
THINK I'VE BEEN FAIRLY
SUPPORTIVE OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT DURING MY
TENURE HERE AND SO WHEN THIS
BILL CAME FORWARD TO MY DESK I
TOOK A LOOK AT IT. AND I TOO
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD AND THE ROLE OF THE
ADVISORY BOARD AND IF IN FACT
THE ADVISORY BOARD HAD THE
ACTUAL AUTHORITY TO- MAKE
DETERMINATIONS- AND IN FACT
MAKE A INITIAL DETERMINATION ON
THE DECERTIFICATION OF. A
PULLEY UP A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER I WONDERED WHY. THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD WAS
THE- WHICH MADE UP THE WAY IT
WAS WITH. A COUPLE PEACE
OFFICERS AND CAN ADVOCATES ON
THE OTHER SIDE THAT- SEEM TO
BE- NUMERICALLY SUPERIOR TO
THOSE OF THE PEACE OFFICERS ON
THE BOARD IN ANY EVENT IT CAUSE
ME SOME. SOME CONCERN AND THEN
I USED TO BE A LAWYER MANY
YEARS AGO I DON'T CLAIM TO BE
SO ANYMORE BUT I DID LOOK AT
THE DEFINITION OF- SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT AND I WAS I WAS
BOTHERED BY THE- THE USE OF
TERMS SUCH AS VIOLATION OF THE
LAW AND I SAID WELL WHAT WAS IT
A FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR. AN
INFRACTION- SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WASN'T DEFINED AND I WAS ALSO
BOTHERED BY. THE FOLLOW ON TO
THAT PHRASE IN ONE OR MORE OF
THE DEFINITIONAL SECTIONS OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT THAT
INCLUDED WORDS LIKE OR OTHER
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR OF A
PEACE OFFICER WORDS LIKE THAT.
AND SO I WAS BOTHERED BY THOSE
THINGS AND I TOOK A LOOK AT- AT
THE BILL. ITSELF AND PERHAPS
I'VE MISSED SOMETHING BUT WHAT
I FOUND WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADVISORY BOARD IN THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD. IS
THAT THE BOARD'S. PURPOSE IN
THE STATUTE. AND THE RESULT OF
FREE IS MAKE RIGHT. ON THE DC.
OF PEACE OFFICERS TO THE
COMMISSION TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN I
LOOKED. AT HOW THAT PROCESS
PLAYS OUT AND IT PLAYS OUT BYE.
THE COMPLAINT. SAID AN
INVESTIGATION BY INVESTIGATING
OFFICERS EMBEDDED IN THIS NEW
DIVISION. IN POST. ANY OF THOSE
INVESTIGATING OFFICERS AND THE
RESULTS OF THE INVESTIGATION
RESULT IN A- RECOMMENDATION OF
THE DECERTIFICATION. NOT THE
OTHER WAY THE OFFICERS THEN NO
NOTIFIED AND THE OFFICER HAS
THE RIGHT TO RESUME REQUEST A
REVIEW. AN APPEAL INCLUDING
THIS REVIEW INITIALLY BY THE
ADVISORY BOARD. AND SO ONLY IF
THIS INVESTIGATION RESULTS IN A
FINDING AND RECOMMENDATION OR
CONCLUSION OF DECERTIFICATION
DOES IT GET TO THE ADVISORY
BOARD AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ADVISORY BOARD IF AN
INVESTIGATION IS NOT INITIATED
APPARENTLY UNDER OTHER
PROVISIONS THE BILL HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO INDEPENDENTLY.
DIRECTOR REQUESTS ARE INITIATED
INVESTIGATION BY THE DIVISION
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DIRECT A PARTICULAR OUTCOME
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. SO AT THE
END OF THE DAY. IF THERE IS A
FINDING OF DECERTIFICATION
THROUGH THE INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS THE ADVISORY BOARD HAS
A PUBLIC HEARING AND DECIDES
CONFIRMS THAT THAT FINDING IS
SUPPORTED BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO POST
TO CONTINUE WITH THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS. THE
ADVISORY BOARD DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY IF THE
INVESTIGATION CONCLUDES THE
DECERTIFICATION IS
INAPPROPRIATE AS I READ THE
BILL TO REVERSE THE
DETERMINATION OF THE
INVESTIGATOR IN THE DIVISION.
AND INDEPENDENTLY INITIATE A
PROCESS TO DECERTIFY. I'LL
STAND CORRECTED IF SOMEBODY CAN
POINT ME TO A SECTION THE
SECTIONS ARE. IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THIRTEEN FIVE
TEN POINT EIGHT FIVE. SURVEY
THAT CETERA SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE BOARD CAN'T RIVERS HIT
INDEPENDENTLY COME UP WITH A
RECOMMENDATION OF
DECERTIFICATION MOVE THAT
FORWARD TO POST. WELL I STILL
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD AND THINK FROM A PUBLIC
PERCEPTION STANDPOINT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PEACE OFFICERS
AND YOU WANT COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES ON THE OTHER SIDE
MAYBE THOSE SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO TWO. I HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHY YOU WOULD MAKE A LAWYER.
HAVING BEEN ONE MYSELF. A
MEMBER OF AN ADVISORY BOARD AS
OPPOSED TO BEING AN ADVISER TO
THE ADVISORY BOARD I'M NOT SURE
THAT THESE CONCERNS. ARE
NECESSARILY DETERMINATIVE AND I
THINK IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
CERTAINLY. THE PROCESS NEEDS TO
MOVE FORWARD AND IN APPROPRIATE
CASES OFFICERS NEED TO BE-
DECERTIFIED AND AS I MAY HAVE
MENTIONED. MY CONCERNS OVER THE
VAGUENESS OF THE DEFINITION OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT WELL I.
THINK IF THOSE ARE NOT CURED
THERE ARE NOT BEING A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS HERE.
ABOUT VAGUENESS AND WHETHER DUE
PROCESS ISSATISFIED. I'M
CONFIDENT AND COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH TO LET THE REGULATORY
PROCESS MOVE FORWARD AND LET
THE REGULATORY PROCESS FLASH
OUTDOORS TERMS. PUT MEAT ON THE
BONES OF THAT THE OFFICERS
INVOLVED IN THOSE THAT ARE.
JUDGING THE OFFICERS HAVE
SUFFICIENT DETAIL TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION IN THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT CASE SO. WITH THOSE
COMMENTS- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROBERTS SENATOR COM
WONDER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO AND APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA. FOR CARRYING THIS
BATTLE- AND THE WATER THIS YEAR
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE YOU
KNOW S. B. TWO. IT IS. IT
REALLY JUST A CONTINUED STEP IN
RE ENGINEERING POLICY BACK TO
ITS APPROPRIATE INTENT
SOMETIMES NOT ORIGINAL INTENT
BUT APPROPRIATE CONTENT. AND I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT SP TWO IS
ABOUT PROTECTING CITIZENS
PROTECTING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROTECTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
I BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THAT CAN
COEXIST. YOU KNOW THE REALITY
IS TODAY. PRACTICE IS NOT
CONSISTNT THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT. ACTRESSES
ARE NOT CONSISTENT POLICIES ARE
NOT CONSISTENTLY APPLIED
CONSISTENTLY ENFORCED. THAT IS
THE ISSUE HOW DO I KNOW THIS
WELL DESERVED TO EXAMPLES THAT
HAPPENED LIKE JUST. ONE LAST
WEEK IN ONE TWO MONTHS AGO. IN
THE SOUTH GATE AREA YOUNG
LATINA. I WAS HAVING SOMETHING
HAD GONE AWRY. TO ENFORCE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAME
TOGETHER. SHE GOT INTO AN
ALTERCATION HE WAS ON ARMED. HE
WAS MAD. ONE OFFICER HEY THERE
THROUGH TO THE GRAND ON THE
GRASS AND LITERALLY STARTED
PUNCHING HER IN THE FACE. IN
THE FACE. HER PARTNER HIS
PARTNER DIDN'T STOP HIM HE'S
NOT READY I'LL STOP IN AND SETS
BUILD DON'T DO THAT. ALL AND HE
DID AND YOU SAW REASON HAPPY IN
HIS HEAD. AND THEY CONTINUE TO
WITH THIS. ABOUT WHY SHE HAD
BEEN ARRESTED. LAST WEEKEND IN
HUNTING BEACH. THERE WAS A
PARTY SOME OF SALVATOR PARTY.
AND OF YOUNG PEOPLE SHOWED UP
FOR THIS PARTY THAT WAS FAKE
OKAY WHEN THEY WERE HERE TO
TAKE THAT. AND STARTED RIGHT.
JUMPING ON TOP OF POLICE.
BREAKING THE GLASS SETTING OFF
SMOKE IN FIERY FIREWORKS
JUMPING IN FRONT OF THE FACES
OF POLICE OFFICERS. THOSE
POLICE OFFICERS HAD NO RIGHT
HERE THEY HAD NOT CALLED IN THE
SWAT TEAM. THEY WERE NOT USING
ANYONE KNOW BILLY CLUBS. THERE
ARE. BUT FOR SOMETHING SO YES.
THERE WAS LOTS OF ORDER. IS
INCONSISTENT. NOW YOU CAN FILL
IN THE REST OF. THE DOCKS ABOUT
WHO WAS WHO. AND WHAT THEY LIKE.
BUT THAT IS THAT THE ROOT OF
THESE EGGS THAT I SHARING WITH
YOU AND AT THE ROOT THIS BIG. I
HAVE TO TELL YOU. RIGHT NOW
BAIL ANSWERS EVERY HIGH WITHOUT
IN EVERY INNING THAT IS NOT THE
G. OF LAW THE JOB OF LAW NOT TO
SORT OF PRESUPPOSED HUMAN
NATURE GOING TO. I ABOUT
GARDENING AND STAY. AND TO PRAY.
AND POLICY AND YES FAITH IN
PEOPLE. TO INTERPRET WITH
CONSCIOUSNESS AND FLEXIBILITY
TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT. AND WHEN
YOU SEE A PATTERN OF A GREAT
BUSINESS THAT IS WHEN YOU STEP
IN AND RE EXAMINE POLICY. BUT
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO PARSE OUT
EVERY SINGLE THING. IN HOPES OF
FINDING THE NOVEL. WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE FAITH IN THE
PROCESS AND MY FRIENDS THIS
THING GETS OFF THE FLOOR IT
STILL HAS TO GO OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. THERE ARE SOME
PROCESS. TO ENGAGE IN THE
QUESTIONS. SO THE REAL QUESTION
IS WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF. WHAT
ARE YOU AFRAID OF WITH THIS
BILL. I HAVE TO TELL YOU HEY
IT'S REALLY HARD TO PROSECUTE A
POLICE OFFICER STANDARD PROOF
KIND OF HIGH. PROSECUTORS DON'T
LIKE TO DO THOSE CASES. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE TO LOSE. I HAVE
TO TELL YOU SOMETHING ELSE. WE
DON'T HAVE A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
ANYTHING. OKAY ANYTHING WE
STRIVE FOR BUT WE DON'T HAVE IT.
NUMBER THREE. WITH REGARDS TO
PEOPLE THOSE WORDS ON THAT
SHEET OF PAPER CATEGORIES
THEY'RE NOT TELLING YOU WHO
THOSE PEOPLE ARE. NEWS FLASH
BLACK FOLKS BROWN FOLKS PRETTY
CONSERVATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE LIKE TO BE
SAFE TO. WE CALLED THE POLICE
TO. SO LET'S NOT PRESUPPOSE
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO
MIGHT FILL THAT CATEGORY ALL
THOSE BOARD MEMBERS TO GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I PREFER TO THINK
THAT WE WILL PASS THIS THAT IT
WILL GO TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
THAT PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THE
ISSUE THAT PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT THEIR NEIGHBORS THAT
PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THEIR
BRETHREN WHO ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT S. B. TO. TWEAK IT
IN WAYS THAT MAKE IT MORE
RIGHTEOUS. BUT ALSO CONSIDER
THIS. WE MAY IN PASSING AND
SPEED TO. CREATE A SCENARIO.
WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FIND COMFORT IN A PROCESS THAT
MAY ALLOW THEM. TO BE SAFE.
BECAUSE NO THE BAD COPS. SO DO
BAD THINGS AND THEY BULLY AND
THEY HARASS INTIMIDATE. AND
THEY MAKE YOU HOLD TO A BLUE
COLOR PUT EVEN YOUR BLUE
BROTHERS AT. AND I WANT TO PUT
THOSE MANY WOMEN. JUST LIKE I
WANT TO PROTECT MY HUSBAND JUST
LIKE I WANT TO PROTECT MY SON.
SO I URGE YOU TO HAVE FAITH.
HAVE FAITH IN THIS BODY IN THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON
THIS DEAL HAVE SOME SENSE AND
SENSIBILITIES ABOUT THEM. AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING PAST THAT IS
RIGHTEOUS AND APPROPRIATE AND
CONSISTENT. BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE ALL LOOKING FOR
CONSISTENCY THE PRACTICE OF HOW
PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED AND KEPT
SAFE AND WHY CERTAIN PEOPLE ARE
NOT. SO I URGE YOU TO VOTE HI.
ON SP TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR COM LONGER CENTER
BECKER. CAN YOU HEAR ME TODAY
YES. FIFTY TWO GREAT
ACCOUNTABILITY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CASES OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
SICH GEORGE FLOYD WAS MURDERED
ONE THOUSAND SIXTY EIGHT PEOPLE
HAVE DIED AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
ONE THOUSAND SIXTY EIGHT PEOPLE.
WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW STATES
THAT DOES NOT HAVE A PROCESS
FOR DECERTIFICATION. EVERY
MONTH ABSOLUTELY ACT ON THE
CERTIFICATION THIS YEAR. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGREES AND THIS
WILL RESTORE. TRUST IT RESTORE
THE CONSISTENCY. THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES TO
FOR TWO. IT WILL RESTORE FAITH.
AND ALLOW US TO WEED OUT THE
BAD APPLES I THINK IT'S NOT
JUST A JUSTICE ACT IN EQUITY
ACT. ALONG THOSE LINES. I
BELIEVE WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD GREATER DETAIL AROUND
THE ACTS THAT MAYOR DE
CERTIFICATION AND EXTENT OF
RETROACTIVITY. I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS GOING FORWARD. AND
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT SB TWO
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I JUST WANTED TO RISE
BRIEFLY. THIS MORNING IN AND
WHILE I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. FOR MANY OF THE REASONS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED BY OUR
MANY COLLEAGUES. I DO WANT TO
SHARE THAT I AM INSPIRED BY THE
DEBATE THIS MORNING. I'M
INSPIRED BY THE HOPEFULNESS. OF
THE CONVERSATION. THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE AS IT CONTINUES
ON. AND I GENUINELY HOPE THAT
WE CAN GET THIS BILL TO A SPOT
WHERE I CAN SUPPORT IT AND MANY
OF THE OTHERS OF US THAT HAVE
CONCERNS. CAN SUPPORT. AS I'VE
SHARED. MY SON IN LAW IS A
POLICE OFFICER CURRENTLY. I
HAVE MANY ERY CLOSE FRIENDS
THAT ARE POLICE OFFICERS. AND I
KNOW. THAT THEY'RE THE GOOD
COPS. AND I KNOW THEY DON'T
WANT TO TOLERATE THE BAD COPS.
AND SO I APPRECIATE SINCERELY
THE AUTHORS OPENING COMMENTS
AND HOW PASSIONATELY AND
SINCERE HE IS IN THE CONCERNED
FOR THIS BILL. AND THE
CONCERNED AND THE PASSION THAT
EACH OF US HAS SHARED THIS
MORNING ON MAKING SURE THAT
THIS BILL BECOMES. WHAT IT CAN
BE. AND THEN I CAN HAVE. ACROSS
THE BOARD SUPPORT AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT THIS MORNING
THAT- I APPRECIATE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE THIS MORNING
AND THE PROFESSIONALISM THAT
WE'VE ALL SHARED IN THESE IN
THIS CONVERSATION IN THIS
DEBATE AND I'M HOPEFUL FOR THIS
BILL COMING BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
FURTHER. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND LET ME
START OFF BY THANKING EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES TO.
LET THEIR VOICE TO THIS
DISCUSSION. THIS AFTERNOON.
IT'S INCREDIBLE VOICE THAT
NEEDS TO BE HEARD. AND IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT TRULY IT'S TIME HAS
CALLED. AND. I'VE LEARNED IN MY
TWENTY PLUS YEARS AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL THE HARDEST THING ARE
THE SIMPLEST THINGS. THE
HARDEST THINGS TO GET DONE
OTHER THINGS THAT MAKE THE MOST
SENSE. AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHICH MAKES THE MOST
SENSE BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
INSIDE YOUR HEART. BE TRUTHFUL
ABOUT YOURSELF YOU HAVE TO
ADMIT THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT.
POLICING TENDERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION AND IT'S NOT HERE TO BUY
THE ENTIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CLEARLY SHOW BIAS THERE'S
INDIVIDUALS WHO CLEARLY COMMIT
CRIMES AND IT'S BEEN DIVISIONS
WHO SHOULD TRULY BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
TRUST. IT'S ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S ABOUT
FAIRNESS. THIS IS NOT AN ANTI
POLICE BUILT ITS EIGHT ANTI BAD
COP BILL AND AGAIN THAT'S WHO
WE ARE TARGETING AND IF YOUR
HEAD IS IN THE SAND IF YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THEY'RE BAD COPS
THEY'RE BAD COPS COPS WHO ARE
GANG MEMBERS THEY'RE COPS WHO
ARE RAPISTS THEY'RE COPS WHO
ARE MURDERERS THERE ARE COPS
WHO WERE ALL THOSE THINGS
FRAMING PEOPLE AND THAT'S THE
REALITY BECAUSE JUST BECAUSE
YOU PUT ON A UNIFORM AND A
BADGE DOESN'T REMOVE YOU FROM
THE TRUMAN FERAL TREES IN THOSE
STANDS BECAUSE. THEY DO COME
OUT. AND I HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE POLICE I HAVE FRIENDS WHO
ARE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE A GOOD
FRIEND THAT WE'VE BEEN FOR
FORTY PLUS YEARS HE JUST WROTE
A BOOK BEING BLACK IN BLUE.
EXPLAINING HIS THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. AS THE LAPD OFFICER
BEING BLACK IN BLUE. IN THE
BIASES THAT HE FACED AS A
POLICE OFFICER THE BIASES THAT
HE CLEARLY SAW IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. PURSES HE
WAS PATROLLING THE WEST SIDE.
AND EVERYBODY WAS GIVEN TE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT WHEN THEY
DO LOOK LIKE HIM. BEING GIVEN
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT AND
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT
TREATING PEOPLE FAIRLY. HOLDING
THOSE OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE WHO
DO NOT TREAT PEOPLE FAIRLY.
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD AND
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BELIEVE
THAT MEMBERS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I CAN DO A BENCH YOU OF THAT.
BECAUSE AGAIN. IF MY WHITE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WERE BEING
TREATED IN THE SAME WAY. AS
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE IN AS MY
OTHER COLLEAGUE FROM ELLIE SAYS
LOOK DEALS ARE BEING KILLED AT
A HIGHER RATE. THAN AFRICAN
AMERICANS RIGHT NOW BY LAW
ENFORCERS. BUT I GUESS IT'S
FINE BECAUSE IF YOU LIVE IN
LAGUNA GAL. FRESNO BEAVER.
FULLERTON ORINDA BAKERSFIELD.
SANTI THANK HER IRVINE SANTA
CLARITA YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES YOU NEVER SEE A
PERSON BEING DRAGGED OUT OF
THEIR HOUSE PICKUP IN BEING
BEATEN TO DEATH OR SHOT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
BUT IT DOES IF YOU'RE BLACK AND
BROWN EVEN IF YOU LIVE IN A
FLOWING COMMUNITIES. THAT'S
FORMER SENATOR KEVIN MURRAY.
WHO'S PROFILED IN BEVERLY HILLS
DRAGGED OUT OF HIS CAR IN
FELONY PRONE TO OUT IN THE
MIDDLE RODEO DRIVE A STATE
SENATOR. HE WAS GIVEN THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT. AND THIS
IS ALL THIS IS ABOUT HOLDING
THOSE OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE. WHO
TRULY ABUSED THEIR POWER. AND
EIGHT BIG DO EXIST THEY'RE NOT
THE MAJORITY OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN. WHO PUT THAT UNIFORM ON
BECAUSE AGAIN. WE WOULD HAVE
ANARCHY IN THE STREET IF THAT
WERE THE CASE. BUT THOSE BAD
OFFICERS DO EXIST. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A FAIR. TRANSPARENT
WAY. AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ABOUT THE COMPOSITION. OF THE
TASK FORCE ADVISORY BOARD. THAT
IS THERE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE END OF
THE DAY. ALL STILL HAS THE
FINAL SAY. THEY STILL HAVE THE
FINAL SAY BUT SOMETHING
STRIKING YOU GUYS SHOULD KNOW
MOST POLICE SHOOTINGS ARE NEVER
REPORTED THEY'RE NOT OBLIGATED
TO REPORT THAT. LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD NOT EVER OBLIGATED TO
REPORT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING SHOT. IT'S ONLY
BECAUSE OF LEGISLATION HAS NOW
DEMANDED BILLS THAT INFORMATION
COME FOR. YES I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT. A LOT OF THINGS. BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ONE THAT SHOULD
BE FAIR IT SHOULD BE. WHERE WE
TRUST THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
RESPOND TO A CALL IT A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE ARE HESITANT TO
CALL THE POLICE BECAUSE THEY'RE
FEARFUL OF WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WHEN THEY GET THERE WE'VE SEEN.
STORY AFTER STORY. AND I AS A
BLACK MAN. MY STORIES PRIOR YOU
NEED TO. FAR DIFFERENT FROM
MOST OF YOU GUYS BECAUSE I
ASSURE YOU. MY WHITE COLLEAGUES
HAVE NEVER HAD TO TALK. YOUR
PARENTS NEVER HAD TO GIVE YOU
THAT TALK. YOU NEVER HAD TO
GIVE THAT TALK TO YOUR CHILDREN
BUT I HIT THE TOP WHEN I GOT MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE. AND THEY TOLD
ME WHAT I SHOULD DO NOT IF I
GET STOPPED. WHEN I GET
STOPPED. AND THAT HAPPENS IN
EVERY BLACK AND BROWN FAMILY
ACROSS AMERICA BECAUSE IT'S NOT
A IF. IT IS A WIN. AND I'VE
LOST TRACK OF THE NUMBER TIMES
I GOT STOPPED BY THE POLICE. AS
A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
MIDDLE OF AUGUST STOP BY THE
SHARES PULLED OUT OF MY CAR
FORCED TO PUT MY HAND ON A HOT
RUNNING CAR IN THE MIDDLE OF
AUGUST ON A BLACK HOOD SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITE I DON'T
LIKE THE WAY YOU LOOK AT ME. I
DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY HE LOOKED
AT ME. OR AS A YOUNG MARKETING
REP WHAT IBM LEAVING DOWNTOWN
LA GOING UP PEOPLE BOULEVARD.
AND I CUT ACROSS THE MYTHS IN
TRAFFIC TO GO UP OLYMPIC HAPPEN
TO GO DOWN THE STREET THAT I
GUESS THE CURBS ARE BARE THEY
STILL WERE SELLING DRUGS OUT
THERE I DON'T STOP NOBODY RAN
INTO MY CAR TO SELL ME ANY
DRUGS. THROUGH THE GOOD TO
OLYMPIC I'M STOPPED BY LAPD BUT
SEE THE IBM FOLDER MY ON MY
FRONT SEAT WHICH IBM EQUIPMENT
ON MY FRONT SEAT. BUT MY CAR
WAS RANSACKED ALL THE STUFF
THROWN ALL AROUND MY CAR AND
I'M PROBABLY STILL ON SOME LIST
OF BEING A SUSPECT PURCHASING
DRUGS AND I PUT MY CAR I NEVER
STOP MY CAR JUST COLLECTED OVER
A STREET BUT THEY SAID THEY.
SELL DRUGS ON. MANY GUYS VERY
THAT. FULL OF THINGS TO HAPPEN
ALL THE DEBT ALL TIME AND THOSE
ARE BAD OFFICERS WHO DO THAT
AND OFFICER WHO ME OUT OF MY
CAR AS I SCHOOLS. ABOUT YEARS
LATER A LIST OF QUESTIONABLE
SHARES AN LAPD I NEVER WOULD
FORGET THAT OFFICER'S NAME. HE
WAS AT THE TOP OF THE LIST. HE
WAS AT THE TOP OF THE LIST. SO
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I CAN SAY THAT
CONVINCE YOU. AT THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. THIS IS
TRULY THE RIGHT THING TO DO IF
WE WANT TO HAVE TRUST WE WANT
TO HAVE CONFIDENCE. IN ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUE SAID ABOUT. WHO
WHO WANTS IS THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE CLEARLY GONE
ON RECORD THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS HAVE GONE ON RECORD
AND SAID WE NEED POLICE REFORM.
HERE IN AMERICA. WE NEEDED HOW
MANY MORE LIVES NEED TO BE LOST
UNNECESSARILY. HOW MANY MORE
WHAT HE PUT MORE VALUE ON A
COMPOSITION ON A BOARD. OR THE
LOSS OF LIFE. I REALLY HAGGLE
OVER THE COMPOSITION ABOARD THE
LOVE LIFE TO CONTINUE TO BE
LOST. BUT SOME OF US ARE USING
THAT AS A OUR REASON TO HIDE
BEHIND THIS. DR KING. OFTEN
STATED THERE COMES A TIME. WHEN
ONE MUST TAKE A POSITION.
THAT'S NEITHER SAFE. NO POLITIC
NOR POPULAR. BUT HERE SHE TAKES
THE POSITION BECAUSE THEIR
CROTCHES TELLS THEM IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. WHAT IS YOUR
CONSCIENCE TELL YOU TODAY
MEMBERS. THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND A NO VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE SAYS I'M FINE WITH
LEAVING THE NAME ON THE KNACK
OF CALIFORNIANS I'M FINE ON
LEAVING THE NEED OF THE KNACK
OF AMERICAN SPECIALLY PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHAT THE YOU LIVE IN A
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY OR POOR
COMMUNITY. AGAIN KEVIN ROSS
JUNIOR LIVED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. HE WAS SHOT AT
THE PARK THAT I GREW UP PLAYING
AT A PARK THAT I CALLED FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS A PARK THAT I
HOSTED JAZZ BOTH OF IT SOME OF
YOU HERE HAVE ATTENDED. I DON'T
LIVE IN A BAD NEIGHBORHOOD. THE
MAJORITY OF MY SECOND MY
NEIGHBORHOOD YES ALPHANUMERIC.
WE MAKE UP THE HIGHEST
EDUCATION THE HIGHEST INCOME
PER CAPITA FOR THE FIFTY TWO
YEARS OF MY FAMILY HAS LIVED
THERE. SO WE DON'T LIVE IN A
HIGH CRIME AREA. BEGIN A FROST
JUNIOR RUNNING ACROSS THE PARK.
GOT SHOT IN THE BACK TWICE. AND
I CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WERE MISTREATED A STELLAR
RODNEY KING. WE ALL REMEMBER
THAT. BEATEN ALMOST WITHIN AN
INCH OF HIS LIFE BY FOUR
OFFICERS SIMPLY BECAUSE HE WAS
SPEEDING. AT A HONDA. LAST TIME
ON THEY DID NINETY MILES HOURS
PRIOR GOING DOWNHILL WITH NO
BRAKES. YOU LOVE A SINGLE
MOTHER. WHO SHOT ON HER PORCH
SIMPLY BECAUSE SHE HELD A
NIGHT. ON THE PORCH AND SAID. I
DON'T WANT MY CAR MY GAS TO BE
TURNED OFF SO I CAN FEED MY
KIDS AND HEAT MY HOME. RON
SETTLES. THE YOUNG MAN ALL
AMERICAN FOOTBALL PLAYER ON HIS
WAY TO THE NFL. STOP BY SIGNAL
HILL POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
HOURS LATER HE'S MYSTERIOUSLY
HONG AND HIS CELL WAS ANYBODY
EVER CHARGE ON THAT NO. IS IT
ALL FOR A YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAN ON HIS KNEES WITH
HIS HANDS UP IN THE STILL SHOT.
THESE ARE KIDS. ON THE NIGHT
LAST YEAR WE'RE DEBATING THIS
BILL THESE YOUNG KIDS HE IS
BEING EXECUTED BY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. AND I JUST GOT DONE.
A YOUNG MAN IN MY DISH. WHAT AS
A SECURE GUARD. WORKING AS A
SECURITY GUARD FINALLY GO TO
COLLEGE AND HE'S RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE POLICE AND HE SHOT. IN
THE BACK. OR OSCAR GRANT.
WAITING FOR TRAIN OUR JOB ON A
TRAIN ON NEW YEAR'S EVE. AFTER
LEAVING A PARTY. FELONY BROWNED
OUT WITH HIS HAND COULD HANDS
CUFFED BEHIND HIS BACK. IN THE
SHOP AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
STEPHON CLARK JUST DOWN THE
ROAD FROM HERE. I MEAN YOU GUYS
WOULD BE OKAY IF YOUR
GRANDCHILD WAS KILLED IN YOUR
BACKYARD ALL THEY GOT WAS A
CELL PHONE. BUT IT HAPPENS. IT
HAPPENS BUT IT DOES HAPPEN IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOO IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO YOUR FAMILY IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO YOUR KIDS AND
THIS IS ALL WE'RE SAYING LET'S
MAKE THE PROCESS FAIR. LET'S
MAKE PEOPLE HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. LET'S YOU KNOW DO
WHAT'S RIGHT AND I DON'T THINK
ANYONE HAS BEEN BADGERED ABOUT
RACE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
ISSUE BUT THE EIGHT HUNDRED
POUND GORILLA- ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM HIS RACE ON EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO THIS PANDEMIC IS
SHOWN WHERE THE PRISONERS EXIST
IN AMERICA WHETHER IT'S HEALTH
DISPARITIES WHETHER IT'S
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION
HAVING INTERNET WHETHER IT'S
FAIR POLICING RACE IS AT THE
CENTER OF ALL OF THOSE THINGS
SO HAVING UNCOMFORTABLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE. I'M
SORRY MY MOTHER HAD TO SAY IT I
HIT DOG YELLS THE LOUDEST SO IF
WE STRUCK A NERVE HEY GOD BLESS
YOU. BUT THERE'S M. NO
AMBIGUITY HERE THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE IS A
MEASURE OF COMMON SENSE THE
MEASURE WHOSE TIME HAS COME AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
ATKINS FIVE BABIES NO BACKER HI
FORTUS NO BRADFORD HI CARREIRO.
CORTESE HI DALLY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO HI A GIVEN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WISH SO HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL LOOK NOW PLEASE
CALL THE HELP THE MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA CABRERO. GLAZER HER
TADO. NEWMAN. FIVE TWENTY SIX
THOSE NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR ATKINS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE SENATOR ATKINS. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
COLLEAGUES I- STOOD ON THIS
FLOOR IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND I MADE A COMMITMENT
TO FOCUS ON HOUSING PRODUCTION.
DESPITE THE CHALLENGES
PRESENTED BY THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE DONE THAT. I AM PROUD OF
ALL OF THE WORK THAT THE SENATE
HOUSING LEAD GROUP AND THE
CHAIR OF OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE
HAVE DONE. TO PUT TOGETHER THE
SENATE HOUSING PACKAGE BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL. I
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK THE
SENATORS FROM SALINAS BERKELEY
SAN JOSE LOS ANGELES LONG BEACH
HEATS BERG RIVER SIDE AND
BALDWIN PARK. FOR THEIR WORK
AND COMMITMENT TO FINDING
SOLUTIONS. THE HOUSING CRISIS
IS AN ISSUE SO LARGE THAT THERE
IS NO SINGLE SOLUTION. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY S. B. NINE IS
A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
FOR MANY OF YOU THIS BILL WILL
LOOK VERY SIMILAR TO A BILL
THAT I AUTHORED LAST SESSION S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT IS SIMILAR WE TOOK A
GOOD BILL THAT MET THE FATE OF
A HARD DEADLINE. AND AFTER
LISTENING TO FEEDBACK FROM
HOMEOWNERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WE
IMPROVED UPON IT. SB NINE
PROVIDES OPTIONS FOR HOMEOWNERS
BY STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
THEM TO CREATE A DUPLEX OR
SUBDIVIDE EXISTING LIED IN A
SINGLE FAMILY ZONED. UP TO FOUR
UNITS. AND I'M GONNA SAY THAT%
AGAIN UP TO ONLY FOUR UNITS.
PRESS B. NINE STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL AND
CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE HOUSING
OPTIONS. AND WE NEED THOSE
OPTIONS MORE THAN EVER TO HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THIS STATE. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
EXISTING TENANTS HISTORIC
DISTRICTS ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
AND COASTAL REQUIREMENTS SB
NINE ESTABLISHES A SPECIFIC
LIST OF QUALIFICATIONS THAT
MUST BE MET. THE BILL ALSO
PROTECTS NEIGHBORHOODS FROM
SPECULATION AND GENTRIFICATION.
LET ME FOCUS FOR A MINUTE ON
EXACTLY HOW IT DOES THAT. S. B.
NINE LIMITS INDIVIDUALS FROM
RECEIVING MINISTERIALLOT
SPLITS ON ADJACENT PARCELS TO
PREVENT INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS. FROM CHANGING THE
LOOK AND FEEL OF NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT ALSO SPECIFICALLY PREVENTS
PROFITEERS FROM ADDICTING ARE
DISPLACING TENANTS BY EXCLUDING
PROPERTIES WERE TENET HAS
RESIDED IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS. IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS
HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE HOUSING LEAD GROUP TO
IMPROVE THIS BILL. ONE
MODIFICATION IS THAT THE BILL
NOW PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE AUTHORITY TO ENACT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENT. ANOTHER
MINUTE MAKE CLEAR THE NUMBER OF
UNITS ALLOWED AND AT THE RISK
OF SOUNDING LIKE A VERY BROKEN
RECORD I'LL SAY IT AGAIN UP TO
FOUR UNITS ONLY. THERE ARE SO
MANY VARIABLES THAT MAKE A
NEIGHBORHOOD WHAT IT IS THE
SIZE OF LIGHTS LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS THE DESIRE OF
HOMEOWNERS TO EVEN USE THIS
OPTION. NOT EVERYONE WILL
CHOOSE TO DO A LOT SPLIT OR
TURN THEIR HOME INTO A DUPLEX
AND THAT IS OKAY. THIS MERELY
OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO THOSE
WHO DO. AND I'D SAY TO THOSE
WHO ARGUE THAT THIS COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE LOOK OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD LOOK AROUND YOU
THEY'RE ALREADY BEAUTIFUL
DUPLEXES AND ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS NEXT DOOR TO TRADITIONAL
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. AND SOME
OF OUR STATE'S MOST SOUGHT
AFTER ZIP CODES. IN MY OWN
DISTRICT HILLCREST NORTH PARK
GOLDEN HILL. HERE IN MY HOME
AWAY FROM HOME OF SACRAMENTO IN
EAST SACRAMENTO AND EVEN LAND
PARK. THESE ARE CHARMING HOUSES
THAT ARE NOT ONLY A BRIGHT SPOT
ON THE STREET BUT A COMFORTABLE
PLACE. FOR NOT JUST ONE BUT TWO
FAMILIES TO CALL HOME. ALONG
WITH THE SAFEGUARDS INCLUDED IN
MY BILL I WANT TO DISCUSS THE
OPPORTUNITY IT PROVIDES FOR
FAMILIES WHO HAVE MORE OPTIONS
TO BUILD. MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSING AND BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL ASSETS.
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH IS A
CURRENCY WE KNOW IS CRUCIAL TO
COUNTERING IN EQUITY AND
CREATING SOCIAL MOBILITY.
ESPECIALLY IN NEIGHBORHOODS
WERE OUTDATED ZONING LAWS HAVE
CREATED BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND IT LED TO
OVERCROWDING. THIS BILL
PROVIDES HOMEOWNERS WITH
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE RENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER WORKING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
TO FIND A HOME IN THEIR PRICE
RANGE. OR WHO MAY BE LOOKING
FOR THEIR OWN PATH TO A MORE
AFFORDABLE HOME OWNERSHIP PLAN.
A CHANCE FOR ADULT CHILDREN TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD A HOME IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY GREW UP.
pDOOR. THIS BILL IS AN EXPANSION
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AND FAMILIES
ALIKE. THE BILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE. REAL
PROGRESSIVE AND POSITIVE CHANGE
AND STRENGTHEN THE FABRIC OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. WITH EQUITY
INCLUSIVITY AND AFFORDABILITY.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR NELSON.
MISPRISION LATER IN JAIL IN THE
SENATE I VOTED FOR THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE. AND I BOUGHT IT. IN
GOOD CONSCIENCE USUALLY I'M
VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT CONSTRAINS LOCAL CONTROL
OR LOCAL AUTHORITY. READING THE
BILL AND LISTENING TO THE
DISCUSSION I DID NOT FIND THIS
BILL TO BE ONEROUS AT ALL IN
THAT DIRECTION. THAT I BELIEVE
IT DOES MAKE GOOD SENSE. ONE
CONCERN I DO HAVE IS THE
SUCCESSOR LEGISLATORS WILL TRY
TO GET EXEMPTED FROM THIS AS
SOME HAVE A VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSING ALLOWANCES. WE CANNOT
LET THAT HAPPEN THIS IS REALLY
A BOTTOM LINE BILL BUT IT IS IT
IS A POSITIVE BILL. IT DOES
MOVE US AHEAD. AND I THINK IN
MANY AREAS IT WILL HELP
OVERCOME THE NEED IN THE
COMPLEX. I WOULD LOOK AT MAYBE
IS A BIT OF A BALANCE. I DON'T
WANT TO CALL THE COMPROMISE
WITH THE BALANCE BETWEEN THOSE
INTERESTS. THAT DON'T WANT TO
HAVE SUCH DENSITY IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS. IT ISN'T THAT
RELATED TO DUPLEXES. THAT IS
NOT THE MOST ONEROUS I'VE LIVED
IN DUPLEXES. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES HERE.
IS THE SOLUTION. AND THE
REPUTATION OF THE PRO TEM
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD. THAT
MEANS THE ITEM AND THE ISSUE IS
TRUST. AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE OF MERIT
WILL BE HELPFUL TO US NOT
STIFLE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT
IT WILL HELP ACCOMMODATE THE
POPULATION. GOALS THAT WE HAVE
GOT TO FINISH HIGHER THAN I
WILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALES. YES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TOO WANT TO EXTEND
MY SUPPORT TO MY PROD CO AUTHOR
OF SB NINE AND SPOKE WITH MANY
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS IN MY
DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY IN LONG
BEACH AND EVEN IN MY OWN HOME
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION IN
TALKING AT LENGTH ABOUT THIS-
THIS BILL AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM ABOUT
THIS DOES TAKE A VERY GOOD
BALANCE IN TERMS OF ENSURING
THAT THERE IS. ADDITIONAL
DENSITY JUST ONE MORE IN MANY
CASES OFTEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OFF ALREADY ALLOW IT- AND
ORDEAL OUT THREE- UNITS ON ONE
LOT THIS ALLOWS JUST ONE MORE
WITH MANY LOCAL PROVISIONS
OWNER OCCUPATION AS WELL AND
HISTORIC EXEMPTION WHICH I
THINK IS A LOT OF WHAT ARE OUR
HOME OWNER ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR THAT- I
HOPE YOU CAN COME TO CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSIONS ON ON HOUSING
AND HOW WE CAN BUILD MORE. BUT
ALSO PUSH THE ENVELOPE AS IT
PERTAINS TO ENSURING THAT ALL
PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY TO LIVE
IN A VERY AFFORDABLE HOMES SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOAT I THINK MY-
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING A PART OF
THE LAST TWO YEARS THAT THIS
WORKING GROUP AND THE PRO
TEMPER HER LEADERSHIP IN THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MR. A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR PLEASE. THE AUTHORS TOOK
TO QUESTION YES I BELIEVE IN
THE HOUSING COULD- A IS ASKED
TIME BY THOSE PHONE IN AND WE
GOT A ANSWER ON RECORD AS TO
WHETHER THEY'RE FOR. HOMEOWNERS
THE QUESTION OF BEING AN
IMPORTANT ONE SINCE THE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITIES IN HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE REALLY BASED
ON THE POPULATION THAT IS THERE
IN TERMS OF MEETING THE COMMON
AREA AND NEEDS AND THE OTHER-
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE IN IN
MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE FEW
MODIFICATION BECAUSE WE'RE IN
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES AND
THOSE ARE ALL ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY OWNERS SO.
THERE IS THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THEY'RE FIVE FAX
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS ALL
RIGHT IN IN. IN THE CASE OF-
DENSIFICATION THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR- PROVISION. QUESTION
IS DOES IT HAVE MORE FACILITY
ASIAN. THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT
THROUGH THE CHAIR AT TO THE
GOOD SAID FROM LAGOON GAL I
KNOW THE INTER OF THE LAW THAT
GOVERN COMMUNITY INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS R. C. I. D.'S AND
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
ALWAYS GENERATED A LOT OF
CONVERSATION BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY- OUR OFFICE HAS
CONSULTED WITH LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL IN SP NINE WOULD NOT
OVERRIDE C. ID OR H. AWAY
RESTRICTIONS. I THINK THAT
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT ANSWER I
THINK THAT THAT DOES RELIEVE A
LOT OF CONCERN ON THE BILL OF
MINE REMAINS OVER THE PARKING
ISSUES AND I THINK I BRING IT
UP ON EVERY. ONE OF THE HOUSING
BILLS BECAUSE PARKING IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN SUBURBIA
AND WHERE THERE IS A TRANSIT
AVAILABLE PEOPLE HAVE CARS I
THINK WE HAVE. A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE DOUBLING
UP PIANO MANY OF THE RENTALS IN
PARTICULAR YEAHAND WE STILL
HAVE NO AUTHORITY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO REULATE. PARKING
WHEN IT IS A PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE SO I'D I WILL REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT I TRULY TRULY
APPRECIATE OPERA THAMES. VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH ON THEIR
FANS OF CONTINUING WORKING WITH
THOSE ARE TWO I THINK RELIEVE
THE CONCERN THAT'S THERE
REGARDING COMMUNITY CHARACTER
AND CERTAINLY. THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES THANK YOU. SO
RUBIO. THANK YOU MUST PRESIDENT
TODAY I ALSO RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHORED AS NINE AND I WANT TO
COME THE PRO TEM FOR BEING SO
THOUGHTFUL AND ALLOWING US TO
HAVE A REALLY ROBUST IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION OF WHAT'S NEEDED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT THIS
BILL WAS BUILT BY CONSENSUS IT
WAS A GROUP OF SENATORS THAT
CAME TOGETHER FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE AND
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. AND FOR
ME PERSONALLY I WAS ABLE TO
BRING THE VOICE OF MY DISTRICT
TO THE TABLE THEY WERE NOT ON
BOARD BUT WE DID TAKE THEIR
CONCERNS TO THE TABLE WE
DISCUSSED THINGS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO INVITE OTHERS LIKE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND EVERYONE THAT
HAS A STAKE IN THIS ISSUE AND
SO I COULD ONLY SAY WITH
CERTAINTY THAT ALL VOICES WERE
HEARD ALL CONCERNS. WERE
ADDRESSED AND WE'VE REALLY
STRESSED TO CREATE A POLICY
THAT GIVES EVERYONE SEVENTEEN
SO I PERSONALLY ONE INCREASE-ALL OF US TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THIS WAS BUILT BY
CONSENSUS AND IT BROUGHT
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE SO WITH
THAT I URGE AND I BUILT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR WARNER.
I THANK YOU MR- HI RIGHT AND SO
OF ESPIONAGE I WANT TO THANK
THE PROTON FOR HER- LEADERS AND
FOR TAKE A VERY- AND MEASURED
APPROACH TO- RESTRICTIVE
ZONING- THIS IS A- BILL THAT
WILL BE VERY IMPACTFUL OVERTIME
AND I THINK A LOT OF TIMES.
WHEN HOUSING DEBATES ESPECIALLY
AROUND ZONING PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES ASSUME THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE LIKE IMMEDIATE OVERNIGHT
CHANGES AND THAT'S JUST NOT
HOW- THE REAL WORLD AT HOUSING
WORKS IS GOOD ABOUT GRADUAL.
CHANGE OVER TIME- TO TRY TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
MORE ABUNDANT HOUSING- SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE HERE
SO THE PEOPLE ARE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES. SO THAT OUR KIDS
AND OUR GRANDKIDS HAVE A SHOT
OF ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO STAY
HERE- THIS IS A VERY VERY
THOUGHTFUL- PROPOSAL I WANT TO
THANK OUR LEADER FOR HER. ON
OUR WORK ON IT AND EVERYONE WHO
HAS HELPED MOVE THIS FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR MEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I WANT ALSO
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR THIS INCREDIBLE BUILT
I THINK IT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND AS WE ALL KNOW WE'RE FACING
A IMMENSE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
STATE- IN MY HOME DISTRICT IN
ORANGE COUNTY- TOO MANY
CHILDREN ARE GROWING UP THEY'RE
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE AND
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
ANYWHERE CLOSE BY- THAT'S
CREATED ALL SORTS OF QUALITY OF
LIFE CONCERNS I'D CREATED
CONGESTION. AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE STATISTICS WE ALL KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA LOST POPULATION LAST
YEAR THOSE WERE NOT RICH PEOPLE
LEAVING THE STATE IT WAS-
WORKING CLASS MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES AND IT LOOKS LIKE
HOUSING AT A COST OF HOUSING
HERE IN THE STATE WAS THE
NUMBER ONE DRIVER WE WANT TO
STAY COMPETITIVE AS AN ECONOMY
WE NEED THOUGHTFUL MEASURES
LIKE THIS AND THE MORE THAT WE
HAVE FOUGHT FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION MEASURES NOW THE
LAST WE'LL HAVE TO LOOK TO
EXTREME MEASURES GOING FORWARD
SO I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK ANY
FURTHER. OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
STATE SENATOR GROW YOUR MIKE UP.
NO OKAY CENTER BACK AND WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND I WILL QUICKLY
CLOSE I- LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE COME OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF THE
ZONING ISSUES IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND HOW DIFFICULT
THEY ARE IT DOES TAKE A LOT OF
WORK- AND AGAIN A MONTH THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR HELPING US
WITH THIS PRODUCT- AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK
SAID THIS WAS A PROCESS. I WAS
NOT ASKED TO RESPOND TO THIS
QUESTION BUT I WILL- IN THE
INTEREST OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LOCAL AGENCIES AS IT RELATES TO
PARKING HOT MAY REQUIRE ONE ALL
STREET PARKING SPOT PER UNIT
ACCEPTED THE PARCELS LOCATED
WITHIN A HALF MILE WALKING
DISTANCE OF HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT. SO I WANTED TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT I HAD THAT IN MY CLOTHES I
WILL JUST COMMENT ON IS THE
ISSUE AROUND VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY AS SEVERITY
ZONES I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
BECAUSE THAT HAS COME UP IN THE
CONVERSATION WITH COLLEAGUES
AND. AS IT RELATES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL. SB NINE
STAR ABOUT BETWEEN FARCE. AND
NEED FOR A HOUSE IN THE STATE
AND IT ALSO CONSIDERS LOCAL
CONTROL. S. B. NINE GOES
FURTHER THAN THE EXISTING
EIGHTY YOU LOG ON FIRE SAFETY.
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE ANY
GEOGRAPHIC RESTRICTIONS ON
WHERE A D. USE MUST BE MINISTER
LEE PERMITTED. AND THAT LAW
ALSO PROHIBITS- AS SOME OTHER
LOCAL- REQUIREMENTS LIKE.
REQUIRING SPRINKLERS IN AN
EIGHTY YOU IF THERE ARE
REQUIRED FOR THE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE BUT THE POINT I
WANTED TO MAKE ABOUT THIS. S.
B. NINE COPIES EXISTING LAW FOR
THE BARN RIGHT WHICH IS A
FORMER- PIECE OF LEGISLATION SB
THIRTY FIVE. FROM OUR COLLEAGUE
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH SAYS
THAT VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES. ARE EXEMPT FROM
THE BILL EXCEPT FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. ALREADY ALLOWS FOR
DEVELOPMENT SO WE PUT THAT BACK
INTO. THE STANDARDS TO REDUCE
COMBUSTIBLE COMBUSTIBLE EDDIE
AND EMBER INTRUSION INTO HOMES.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
REGULATIONS FOR ROAD STANDARDS
WATER SUPPLIES FOR FIREFIGHTING
SIGNAGE FUEL BREAKS EXCEPT
YOUR- DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REGULATIONS. AND THE STANDARDS
WOULD BE STRENGTHENED IF WETAKE UP ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- S. B. TWELVE FROM
A COLLEAGUE WHICH IS PENDING ON
THE SENATE FLOOR THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
APPROVING NEW RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS. IN THESE ZONES
UNLESS DEVELOPMENT CAN MEET
STRINGENT NEW REQUIREMENTS. ALL
I ASK THESE QUESTIONS WE ARE AS
A BODY IN THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING ON HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
THE VARIOUS ISSUES TAKEN AN
INCREDIBLY DETAILED. DEEP DIVE
THOUGHTFUL LOOK INTO HOW TO
MAKE THESE. DIFFICULT
DECISIONS- MAKES SENSE AND BE
RESPONSIBLE WE ARE RESPECTING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERSHIP
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL WE ARE
ASKING OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
WORK WITH US WE ARE TRYING TO
GIVE THEM THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES TO BRING
DOWN THE COST OF HOUSING. AND
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR PRODUCTION
HAPPEN AND ON TOP OF THAT IN
OTHER WAYS WE'RE PROVIDING
RESOURCES AND MONEY FOR
INCENTIVE POSITION TO DO THAT
SO. I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COLLEAGUES. WHO SPOKE TODAY
YOUR FAITH AND TRUST IN IN ME
AND OUR PROCESS- AS WE TRY TO
DO. GOOD WORK AND MOVE
PRODUCTION ALONG AND I JUST
WANT TO ADD MY THANKS IN- ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. ALAN.
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASED NO
BACKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD I
KERR BY ERROR HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. I DON HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG I WISH SO I
HER TADO HI JONES NO KAMMERER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE THE MON.
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. NO MAN
I NEWMAN. NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
VOGUE. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO
I. ROSS HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER
I STERN. AMBERG I Y. CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL NOW. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL UP TO
MEMBERS. ALAN GLAZER. CAN
LONGER. LIMONIUM NEWMAN. STERN
THE CLOSER. PRICE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FALL ITEM ONE FORTY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP THAT'S B. TWO SIX TWO.
INDEED I AM HIS RESIDENT ID I
AM. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM ONE THREE
THREE CALL THAT I READ I'M
SORRY. SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO BAIL. INNER HURTS
REPORTERS I'LL TAKE THE CALL
ROLE- BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY. TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT
FOR REFORM BUT MY JOINT AUTHOR
FROM BERKELEY. MY BRILLIANT
JOINT AUTHOR FROM BERKELEY AND
MANY OF THE SENATORS HERE ON
THIS FLOOR HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR MANY YEARS. THAT CAUSES
BAIL REFORM. ALMOST THREE YEARS
AGO A NUMBER OF US IN THIS
CHAMBER AUTHORED AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT BAIL REFORM MEASURE
BASED UPON THE CONCLUSIONS THE
ADVICE OF THE COUNCIL OF THE
CHIEF JUSTICE IS PRE TRIAL
REFORM GROUP IN FACT THE LADY
TAKING THIS UP IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN ORDER TO GET THE
COUNSELING ADVICE OF THOSE
ESTEEMED JUDGES IN ALL PARTS OF
THE STATE. THAT MEASURE WAS SP
TEN. IN ADVANCING SP TEN I
STOOD ON THIS FLOOR WITH MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES. WITH EVERY
OUNCE OF PASSION THAT I COULD
MUSTER IT MADE THE CASE AS TO
WHY WE NEED BAIL REFORM. THE
MONEY BAIL SYSTEM TURNS
PEOPLE'S LIVES UPSIDE DOWN IN
THE SYSTEM SYSTEMICALLY UNFAIR
TO MANY TO SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
THE REALITY THE CALIFORNIA
UNREASONABLY HIGH BAIL AMOUNTS
SERVICES THE FACTO PRE TRIAL IS
DOWN RIGHT UNJUST. AND THE
CURRENT SYSTEM COST TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WITHOUT
MAKING THEM ANY SAFER. THAT
BILL PASSED OUT OF THIS CHAMBER
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS WITH
TWENTY SIX VOTES. AND WAS
SIGNED BY ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUT ONE OF OUR BAIL REFORMS
MOST VOCAL CHAMPIONS. GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN WHAT FOLLOWED WAS
THE REPEAL OF SB TEN BY THE
VOTERS AFTER DECEPTIVE CAMPAIGN
FUELED AND FINANCED LARGELY BY
THE DEEP POCKETS OF THE BELL
INDUSTRIES AND THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES OR SHOULD SAY THE
HEDGE FUNDS THAT OWN THE
INSURANCE CARRIERS. HOWEVER I
AM NOT HERE TO DWELL ON THAT
OUTCOME. I RESPECT THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
OUR DIRECT DEMOCRACY. BUT HAT
IS EXACTLY WHY WE INTRODUCED
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY S.
B. TWO SIXTY. TWO ENTITLED THE
SAFE AND RESILIENT COMMUNITIES
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BECAUSE IN REJECTING PROP
TWENTY FIVE THE VOTERS WERE NOT
SAYING I SUPPORT MONEY BAIL
SYSTEM THEY WERE SAYING I DON'T
SUPORT THIS APPROACH TO
REFORMING THE BAIL MONEY
SYSTEM. THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST
PROP TWENTY FIVE WAS ABOUT.
UNFAIR MONEY BAIL BUT LET ME BE
CLEAR IT IS NEVER ASKED THE
VOTERS TO SUPPORT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
WE WENT BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD TO SHARPEN OUR PENCILS
AND REFINERY APPROACH. AND LOOK
FOR A DIFFERENT SOLUTION TO
WHAT REMAINED A SYSTEMICALLY
UNFAIR AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
SYSTEM OF BAIL. WESUCH A
REFORM RATHER THAN REPLACE TO
CREATE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
WITHIN THE EXISTING STRUCTURE
OF BAIL WITHOUT RELYING ON
ALGORITHMS A RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS WHICH WERE THEFOCUS OF
THE CAMPAIGN ON PROP TWENTY
FIVE. WE WANTED TO BE A 100%
SURE THAT OUR FRAMEWORK IN NO
WAY RESEMBLED S. B. TEN. FOR
GARDENS WE AGAIN LOOK TO THE
COURTS TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
TO ENSURE THAT OUR NEW APPROACH
HAS BEEN VETTED BY THE COURTS
THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTED THAT IT
WORKED IT WAS PRACTICAL. AND WE
ADOPTED A ZERO BAIL POLICY
ENACTED BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
LAST SPRING. WE KNOW THIS
APPROACH CAN WORK. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE FIVE MONTHS THAT
THE POLICY WAS IN PLACE JAIL
POPULATIONS MEMBERS JAIL
POPULATION STATEWIDE. DECLINED
BY 30% WITHOUT ANY SIGNIFICANT.
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON CRIME RATES
IN MAJOR CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
FACT. THIRTY ONE COUNTIES HAVE
RETAINED THE ZERO BAIL POLICY
IN SOME FORM. SINCE THEN THE
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY AND I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO SOME TREMENDOUS
THINGS HAPPENED IN THE WORLD OF
BAIL REFORM IN LATE MARCH OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPREME COURT
RULED IN THE CASE OF KENNETH
HUMPHRIES A SIXTY SIX YEAR OLD
MAN WHO STOLE SEVEN DOLLARS AND
A BOTTLE OF COLOGNE WAS HELD IN
CUSTODY WITH BAIL SET AT AUST
ASTRONOMICAL AMOUNT THAT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO AFFORD. IN ITS
DECISION THE SUPREME COURT
CONCLUDED QUOTE THE COMMON
PRACTICE OF CONDITIONING
FREEDOM SOLELY ON WHETHER AN
ARRESTEE CAN AFFORD. BAIL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I REPEAT THE
SUPREME COURT SAID THE COMMON
PRACTICE OF CONDITIONING
FREEDOM SOLELY ON WHETHER AN
ARREST YOU COULD AFFORD BAIL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE RULE THIS
THAT THEY MUST CONSIDER THE
ABILITIES OF THE ARRESTEES
ABILITY TO PAY IN SETTING BAIL.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE MEMBERS IS
DESPITE ALL THE ARGUMENTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN ON THIS FLOOR IN THE
OTHER CHAMBER AND HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED. THE ISSUE HAS BEEN
LITIGATED AND ADJUDICATED THE
FIGHT OVER THE LEGALITY OF THE
CURRENT MONEY BAIL SYSTEM IS
OVER. IT IS OVER. AND I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY SHARE WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THIS CHAMBER. A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS THAT THE
COURT MADE BECAUSE THOSE THE
PRECISE TO THE POINT THAT ME
AND OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE MADE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND NOW
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN A
SUPREME COURT DECISION. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PRE TRIAL
DETENTION ARE ON ARRESTEES THEY
SAID ON THEIR LIVES OR MENTION
PROFOUND BECAUSE IT HEIGHTENS
THE RISK OF LOSING A JOB. A
HOME IN CUSTODY OF A CHILD. THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THEY SAID FORCES
THE STATE TO BEAR COSTS OF
FEEDING AND HOUSING ARRESTEES
THE COULD BE PROPERLY RELEASED
THEY SAID. PART OF THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S
HYPE A PRE DETENTION. RATE AND
OTHER STATES MAY ARISE FROM THE
FACT THAT EVEN WHEN THE BAYLESS
TECHNICALLY ALLOWED THE AMOUNT
THAT MUST BE POSTED IS
CONSIDERABLY HIGHER. IN
CALIFORNIA ON AVERAGE THAN
ELSEWHERE THE ARGUMENTS THAT WE
MADE. OVER AND OVER AGAIN. IT
IS THE LAW THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE
HUMPHREY'S DECISION WAS OUR
SUPREME COURT STATEMENT OF
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES ON
PRE TRIAL JUSTICE. AND THIS
MEASURE S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO
PROVIDES A CLEAR AND EFFECTIVE
BLUEPRINT FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SUPREME COURT'S DECISION ON
THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL ALLEY OF
THE CURRENT MONEY BAIL
STRUCTURE. WE NEED A BLUEPRINT
AND S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO IS THAT
BLUEPRINT. IT IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
MAKES CRITICAL REFORMS TO THE
EXISTING BILL FRAMEWORK USING
STATED PRINCIPLES INVENTED
POLICIES OF THE SUPREME COURT.
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HERE'S
WHAT IT DOES IN ESSENCE FIRST
IT LEVELS THE PRE TRIAL PLAYING
FIELD BY SETTING BAIL AT ZERO
DOLLARS FOR MISDEMEANORS AND
LOW LEVEL FELONIES. WITHOUT
ALLOWING REPEAT OFFENDERS TO
GAME THE SYSTEM SECOND. IT
ENSURES THAT THE ACCUSED DO NOT
ASSUME ANY COSTS OF COURT
IMPOSED REACH. CONDITION REALLY.
THREE REQUIRES BELL COMPANIES
TO REFUND THE PREMIUMS THEY
RECEIVE FOR PEOPLE. WERE
ARRESTED BUT ARE CHARGED BUT
WHO HAVE THEIR CASES DISMISSED
REMAKE ALL OF THEIR COURT
APPEARANCES. THE CURRENT BAIL
SYSTEM BASICALLY THEY CHARGE UP
FRONT YOU DON'T GET CHARGED A
YEAR THEY THEY GET YOU OUT OF
JAIL THEY DON'T GET CHARGED.
YOU STILL LOSE YOUR MONEY
COMPLETELY UNFAIR SOMETHING YOU
DON'T SEE IN ANY OTHER PART OF
THE LAW. AND BY CODIFYING THE
OPERATIVE LANGUAGE HUMPHRIES
MUCH OF WHICH I JUST QUOTED. IT
FROM THE SUPREME COURT S. P.
TWO SIXTEEN TO INSURERS THAT
WHERE BAIL IS APPROPRIATE.
COURTS DON'T SEE IT. HIGHER
SAID IT HIGHER THAN WHAT THE
ACCUSED CAN REASONABLY AFFORD.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. S. B.
TWO SIXTY TWO IMPLEMENTS THE
HOPPER DECISION IMPLEMENTS
ADDITIONAL COUNCIL ZERO BILL
POLICY WHICH HAS A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD. AND PROHIBITS THE
UNFAIR USER YES AND PREDATORY
PRACTICES THE BILL IS FOR HIS
ENGAGING FOR FAR TOO LONG. NOW
THAT IT'S YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TAKEN SOME AMENDMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO CERTAIN ISSUES ON
THE HUMAN TRACK I'M ON ON THE-
ZERO BAIL HATE CRIMES HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CHILD ABUSE ELDER
ABUSE. ASSAULT WITH FORCE TO
CALL GREAT BODILY INJURIES
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
THERE'S A FEW OTHER ONES AND
DOMESTIC TERRORISM. AND
POSSESSING A GUN NEAR SCHOOL.
WE CLEARLY WILL DEAL WITH THOSE
EXCEPTIONS WE HAVE DEALT WITH
THE REVOLVING DOOR ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS THING. AND I'VE
GOTTA SAY IN JUST THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM
OF MONEY BAIL IS OBSOLETE. IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN IT COST US
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITHOUT KEEPING US ANY
SAFER. AND WE HAVE DATA FROM
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE COUNTY
QUEST THE STATE. INCLUDING
RIGHT HERE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
EXCUSE ME RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SIMPLE TEXTING
MESSAGES TO FOLKS. CAN INSURE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THEIR COURT
DATES PEOPLE NOT LEAVING TO GO.
TO AN ISLAND OR SOMEPLACE THAT
DOESN'T HAVE AN EXTRADITION
TREATY THEY'RE DEALING WITH
THEIR FAMILY ISSUES ALL THE
KINDS OF THINGS THE COURT JUST
TALKED ABOUT. AND THEY JUST
SIMPLY IS SIMPLY REMIND UNDER
THE SIMPLE. MEMBERS I THINK YOU
KNOW ME TO WELL I HAVE DONE MY
HOMEWORK. THE BUDGET CHAIR HAS
DONE HER HOMEWORK THE OTHER
MEMBERS WHO'VE BEEN PART OF
THIS COALITION AND THE OTHER
COALITION OF. FOLKS INCLUDING
DIANNE GRIFFITHS WHO'S USED TO
BE WORK WORKS WITH THE PROTEST
NEEDS TO WORK WITH ME AND
OTHERS AS USUAL COUNTS AND
OTHERS. HAVE WORKED THEIR HEART
OUT. DEALING WITH THE DETAILS
AND FEELINGS OF DOING THEIR
HOMEWORK TO GET THIS ISSUE
RIGHT. FOR YEARS WE'VE ALL
WORKED TOGETHER ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUES AND IMMERSED
OURSELVES IN THE DETAILS THE
FRAMEWORK WE PROPOSE WORKS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A FEW
CHANGES THAT WILL SEE HOPEFULLY
THE OTHER HOUSE BUT IT IS FAIR
IT'S JUST AND WE MUST ACT NOW.
TO PUT THE BLUEPRINT TOGETHER
OF WHAT THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT SAID WHEN THEY SAID THAT
THE CURRENT MONEY BAIL SYSTEM
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL I ASK THE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR NELSON. THIS PRESIDENT
JOAN OF THE CENTER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION. S. CHAMBERTHE
WATER PRISON TERMS I GOT TO SEE
THE MERITS OF THE BAIL SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA. IT DOES ENSURE
JUSTICE IT DOES ENSURE JUSTICE
FOR SOCIETY LET'S THINK ABOUT
THAT JUST A BIT. BAIL SCHEDULES
ARE SET AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT'S AN ACCOUNTABILITY FACTOR.
MOST ASSUREDLY DALE ENSURES
THAT THE CONVICTED. OR THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT NOT THE
CONVICTED WITHIN YOUR CUES WILL
THEN DO THEIR DUE DILIGENCE YOU
SHOW UP IN COURT. I DON'T AGREE
THAT EVERYBODY WILL JUST SHOW
UP. THE RECORD DOESN'T REALLY
SUPPORT THAT. MANY SKIPPED BAIL.
BAIL IS A VERY USEFUL TOOL. AND
THEN YOU HAD ANOTHER WAY. SEAN
THE MONUMENT. I GO. THEY'RE
VALUABLE ADJUNCT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHAT DO I NEED.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT NOW. DOES
NOT HAVE THE REACH TO DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES. THE CHANGE
BAIL JUMPERS. BONDSMEN ARE THEN
AN EXTRA ARM FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE CITIZENS
PROTECTION FOR THE INSURANCE AT
THE INS SERVICE RIGHT THE
JUSTICE OF THE SYSTEM OF THE
SYSTEM. WHEN A CRIMINAL HAS A
GREEN SUN CITIZEN BE THAT A
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY. OUR
MURDER RATE YOUR NAME. THIS IS
A DISCIPLINE TO ENSURE THAT
THE- ACCUSED IS GOING TO SHOW
UP FOR JUST THE SEARCH. AND
THAT'S NOT ABOUT ENRICHING ANY
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY THAT IS
ABOUT INSURING. THE COMFORT IN
THE PEACE. OF JUSTICE.
CORRECTIONS OF CALIFORNIA. NOW
IF LAST YEAR'S BILL WAS SO
PERFECT. THEN WHY DID WE HAVE
TO THEN. WAIT FOR A SUPREME
COURT DECISION TO CORRECT THE
COURSEAS THIS BILL PURPORTS TO
DO. I WOULD SUBMIT IT PROBABLY
MAKES IT BETTER LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD THROW OUT. DALE
THIS IS MAYBE A BIT OF A
COMPROMISE BY THE PROPONENTS
HOLD THE WORST CRIMES. FOLKS
WERE LEFT IN THE LEFT WORST
CRIMINALS OUT OF PRISON TODAY.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE WE'LL
GET TO THAT ANOTHER MATTER
ANOTHER DEBATE. I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT. FOR US
TO RETAIN THE DISH ONE OF BAIL
THAT HAS WORKED WELL FOR MANY
DECADES. WHO DID IT NOT WORK
OUT WELL FOR. WELL IT DIDN'T
WORK OUT TOO HOT FOR THE
ACCUSED. WHO WANTED TO RUN.
LET'S GET BAIL AND NOT FACE
JUSTICE. KEEP IN MIND THAT IT
IS NOT JUST THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT IS ALSO AN ASPECT A PUBLIC
SAFETY IN A CHURCH THAT THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
HOLD THEIR JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS.
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS SHOW UP IN
COURT. AND IN NO SMALL MEASURE
BECAUSE- THE BAIL BONDS. PUT
THEIR LIVES AT RISK. TO ENSURE
THAT JUSTICE IS DONE I URGE A
NO VOTE. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I
AM THE WE USED TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR BEST B. TWO SIXTY TWO
I'M NOT A LAWYER SO I HAVE TO
EXPLAIN THINGS SIMPLY BUT NOT
INACCURATELY AND MY YEARS ON
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE I
HAD TO LEARN HOW TO PARSE. THE
LAW. TWO IN A WAY BECAUSE WHEN
I WOULD HEAR VARIOUS TESTIMONY
AND NOT BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
IT I HAD TO SPEND HOURS. REALLY
TRYING TO WORK WITH FOLKS TO
HELP ME BREAK IT DOWN AND
UNDERSTANDING SO LET ME TELL
YOU IN MY SIMPLE WORDS. THAT WE
HAVE A SITUATION NOW. BECAUSE
OF MONEY BAIL IF YOU CAN PAY
BAIL. YOU GET OUT OF JAIL. BUT
IF YOU CAN'T YOU HAVE NO CHOICE
AND YOU HAVE TO STAY THERE. AND
THAT WILL TEST FOR FREEDOM.
MEANS THAT THOSE WHO ARE FORCED
TO WAIT IN JAIL FACE A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR CHILDREN.
OR LOVED ONES CAN BE REMOVED
pTHEIR JOBS. THEY CAN LOSE THAT
WHERE THEY LIVE BECAUSE THEY'RE
SITTING IN JAIL MAYBE THEY
DIDN'T PAY RENT. I REMEMBER
TESTIMONY ONCE IN A PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WHERE THERE
WAS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
JAIL FOR SIX YEARS AWAITING. A
COURT CASE TO SEE WHETHER THEY
WERE. INNOCENT OR GUILTY SIX
YEARS DO YOU KNOW THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE MORE. IF
YOU'RE REMOVING YOUR HOME FOR
SIX YEARS. NOW THE THING ABOUT
IT IS THAT THESE ALL HAPPEN
BEFORE THERE IS A DETERMINATION
OF GUILT OR INNOCENCE. SO YES
YOU'VE BEEN ACCUSED OF THE
CRIME BUT YOU'VE NOT YET BEEN.
AT THE COURT HAS NOT YET RULED
YOU CONVICTED. WELL S. B. TWO
SIXTY TWO DOES NOT ELIMINATE
MONEY BAIL FORTUNATELY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN
RULING WHEN THE HUMPHREY
DECISION GAVE US SOME GUIDANCE
THAT ALLOWED US TO EMBODY THAT
IN THIS BILL IN SP TWO SIXTY
TWO AND ESSENTIALLY SP TWO
SIXTY TWO ALLOWS THOSE WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO PAY TO RECEIVE
THE SAME JUSTICE AS SOMEONE WHO.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR MEANT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO. ECHO THAT AND THANK
THE AUTHORS FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND- FROM BERKELEY FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL IN
ADDRESSING IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE I WANT TO
PARTICULARLY COMMEND THEM. FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THIS WAS A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH FROM
EXEMPTING VIOLENT CRIMES HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND IMPORTANTLY DURING THIS
TIME HATE CRIMES I HATE CRIMES
ARE AS WE KNOW ALL OUR
ACCELERATING AT A RAPID RATE
INCLUDING IN MY HOME DISTRICT
IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT CERTAIN
TYPES OF CRIMES- THAT WE TREAT
THEM MORE SERIOUSLY AND I JUST
WANTED TO AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THAT
AMENDMENT HIRES MICHAEL. THANK
YOU SENATOR I CALL SKI. MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SIXTY TWO I WASN'T GOING
TO- SPEAK ON IT BUT I- IN THE
DISCUSSION ON THE PREVIOUS BILL
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS AUTHORED
AND NICK IN THE CONCERNED THE
PERCEPTION THAT THE PUBLIC HAS-
I BELIEVE I COMMEND THE AUTHORS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE HUMPHREY
CASE WHICH I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF READING. REALLY PLACES A
DUTY UPON THIS LEGISLATURE TO
DO SOMETHING TO RESPOND TO THAT
THE FINDINGS AT THE HEAD AS HE-
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY SAID IN THIS COMMON
PRACTICE IS COMMON PRACTICE OF
HAVING. LOCAL COURTS SET THE
BAIL BAIL SCHEDULE THE YOU KNOW
THOSE OF US WHO PRACTICE A
LITTLE BIT IN THE CRIMINALLAW
ARENA SO MANY TEACHERS JUDGES
DON'T EVEN CONSIDER. THE TIES
THAT THE PERSON HAS THE
COMMUNITY THEY SIMPLY LOOKAT
THE BAIL SCHEDULE ON SAY BOOM
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY THIS AND
THE- THE- THE HUMPHREY'S
DECISION CLEARLY SAYS THAT THIS
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL WE CAN'T
JUST. SIT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY. OKAY WHAT
DO WE DO WHAT WE DO NOW. THE
AUTHORS AT THE IS IT ELOQUENTLY
OF SPACE SPOKEN. CAREFULLY
LOOKED AT THE HUMPHREY'S
DECISION AND IS IMPLEMENTED
THIS END THE PROVISIONS THAT
THEY GIVE TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL EACH YEAR GO OVER AND
SET WE STARTED ZERO FOLKS. THE
WHOLE WORLD IN CALIFORNIA KNOWS
IT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
START AT ZERO ON ON THE BELT
AND THEN IF WE HAVE THESE. THE
FACTS ARE GOING TO DETERMINE IF
THEY'RE DANGEROUS ENOUGH THE
RELEASING OF THE COMMUNITY.
WARRANTS S. R. I. SCHEDULE THEN
WE'RE GONNA LOOK IT OVER A BILL
THEN WE CAN LOOK AT THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY SO I AM
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THIS THE-
THE- THE- CALL TO DUTY R.
PONDRE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
LISTENED TO BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER. AND I- VIRGIN I'VE-
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. EARNINGS SEEN NINE. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
RIGHT ALL I'M SURE I'M SURE I'M
SORRY CENTERBRIDGE BIRD PLEASE
NOTE FOR THE CLOSE I JUST
INSPIRED BY THE COMMENT THAT.
BY THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT
JUST MADE ABOUT OUR DUTY. I
THINK YOU HIT IT ON THE ON THE
HEAD. WITH THE ARGUMENTS ABOUT
THE CURRENT BILL STRUCTURE WE
STILL HAVE BAIL. IT REALLY IS
AS MY JOINT OFFER INDICATED THE
ABILITY TO PAY. SO INSTEAD OF
HAVING THESE ARBITRARY. NUMBERS
IT DOESN'T LOOK AS THE PERSON
IN THE I. AS IF BEING. A JUDGE
THERE CERTAIN. SO CAN DO TO
THEIR FLIGHT RISK AND THEIR
PUBLIC RISK. INSTEAD OF JUST
HAVE A PRICE LIST FOR YOUR
LIVER. ITS BASE SAYS THAT THE
ESSENCE OF OUR CONSTITUTION IS
ABOUT YOU GOT TO TREAT PEOPLE
AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND YOU CAN'T
ARBITRARILY SET NUMBERS AND SET
A BAIL SCHEDULE THAT SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS. IT DOESN'T
WORK SECONDLY WHAT WE KNOW BY
VIRTUE WHAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY ISN'T ALTERNATIVES
WORK. THE I WANT TO RESPECT THE
POINT- FROM THE CENTER IN THE
NORTH OR VALOR AWARDS WHICH
CITY IT IS FROM. NIELSEN R. R.
DEAN I SHOULD SAY. YOU KNOW THE
SYSTEM HAS INVOLVED THE OWN MY
DAD KNEW SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
HEARD THIS WAS AN OLD JAILHOUSE
LAWYER IN THE FORTIES IN LOS
ANGELES. YOU GIVE A HUNDRED
DOLLARS THE CLERK MAJOR YOU MAY
BACK TO COURT AND YOU GOT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS BACK IF YOU
WANTED THAT SCENE OUT. IT
EVOLVED AND MORPHED INTO A
BUSINESS THAT IS OWNED BY HEDGE
FUNDS. BECAUSE IT'S SO
PROFITABLE. THE FRONT LINE.
AGENTS THAT BAIL AGENTS THOSE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OFTEN DOING
THE WORK AND PROBABLY AREN'T
MAKING VERY MUCH MONEY. IT'S
THE HEDGE FUNDS ARE MAKING THE
MONEY. BECAUSE THEY SAW. THAT
THERE'S THIS QUIRK IN THE LAW
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO JUST PRINT
MONEY IS ONE COMPANY THAT WE
FOUND IN A REPORT. THAT HADN'T
PAID A BILL CLAIM IN SEVENTEEN
YEARS. BETTER THE DRUG
BUSINESS. YOU NEVER KNOW ALL
THE YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE THE
ROACH MOTEL MONEY GOES AND
NOTHING COMES OUT. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED SO NOW
WE HAVE DATA. WE HAVE A SUPREME
COURT GUIDANCE. AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS THE CENTER FOR FREMONT
SAID. AS A LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT FOLLOWING THE
DIRECTIONS OF THE SUPREME
COURT. AND PUTTING TOGETHER A
BLUEPRINT THAT'S OUR DUTY. TO
BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
SYSTEM THAT EMBODIES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES THAT
THEY DISCUSSED. THAT EMBODIES
THE LINE THE LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED AS A RESULT OF BAIL
REFORM ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
PUTTING TOGETHER A SYSTEM
THAT'S FAIR THAT'S JUST FOR
EVERYBODY. THAT PROTECTS THE
PUBLIC COST THE PUBLIC LESS
MONEY. AND THAT WORKS IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW'S THE TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU. NOW MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM. ONE FORTY. ALAN I
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
CORTESE. HI DALLY NO DODD HI
THERE AWESOME HI ADNAN. GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN HI
NEWMAN I NELSON. NO A SHOW BOTH
NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS-
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN I
AM BERG RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER HI WILKE NO. THEN REMOVE
THE CALL NOW MEMBERS REMOVING
OUT THE FOLLOWING. THIRTY NINE.
BY SENATOR SKINNER YOU'RE
PREPARED SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHTY
ONE BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO SENTENCING.
DINNER'S DINNER FOR GEORGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FOR THE PAST YEAR I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON A
STATEWIDE COMMITTEE. ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE AND
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDED UC IRVINE LAW SCHOOL
DEAN SONG RICHARDSON GOVERNOR
PETE WILSON'S- APPOINTED
JUSTICE JUSTICE KARL MARINO AND
RETIRED SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
PETER ESPINOZA. S. B. EIGHTY
ONE THE BILL I'M PRESENTING NOW
IS THE PRODUCT OF THAT
COMMITTEE AND IT WAS
CONSTRUCTED PRIMARILY BY THE
JUDGES. ARE IN THAT A BODY WHO
BASE THEIR EXPERIENCE. WHILE
THEY WERE ON THE BENCH DEALING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS.
S. B. EIGHTY ONE DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ANY SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT INSTEAD ITS
APPROACHES TO ESTABLISH CLEAR
GUIDANCE. ON THE APPLICATION OF
SENSE AND HENCE MINTS WHILE
RETAINING JUDGES AUTHORITY TO
APPLY AN ENHANCEMENT TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY. SO WHILE THE
CENTENNIALS MINTS ON THEIR FACE
MAY SEEM STRAIGHTFORWARD THE
RESEARCH REVIEWED BY OUR
COMMITTEE AND THE STAKEHOLDER
TESTIMONY RECEIVED EXPOSED VERY
DEEP INCONSISTENCIES IN THEIR
APPLICATION. WHERE THE SAME
BASIC CRIME ONE PERSON MAY HAVE
GOTTEN NO SENSE ENHANCEMENTS
ANOTHER MAY HAVE GOTTEN THREE.
SO DUE TO THE LACK OF CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO APPLY THE
ENHANCEMENTS AND WHAT BASIS TO
DISMISS THEM. S. B. EIGHTY ONE
IS DESIGNED TO HELP REDUCE
THOSE AND THE BILL AS I
MENTIONED IS BASED ON THAT
EXPERIENCE AND INSIGHT. OF
THOSE JUDGES TO HELP PROVIDE
CLEAR GUIDANCE AND RETAIN
JUDICIAL AUTHORITY AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF SENATOR NELSON.
BUT A PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I. URGE A
NO VOTE- THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. REPEATEDLY THROUGH
THE INITIATIVE. AND UNDERSTAND-
THE INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL THOSE VERY SACRED TRUSTS
AND AUTHORITIES OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE UNDER ATTACK
NOW. FROM MANY QUARTERS. PEOPLE
WANT TO DENY. THE DIRECT
DEMOCRACY THAT WE ENJOY NOW.
BACK TO THE ISSUE. I'VE
ENHANCEMENTS OVER THE DECADES
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE WAYS WE
HAVE ENSURED JUSTICE. PHIL IF
YOU ELIMINATE THE ENHANCEMENT
YOU'RE STILL MAKE A LOT OF THE
THING DIDN'T HAPPEN. THE USER
OF THE GUN WELL THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN. THE BURGLARY ROBBERY
YEAH THAT HAPPENED BUT THESE
OTHERS DIDN'T- THE ABSURD
EXCUSES BEEN USED IN THE PAST
THAT THIS IS STACKING. STAFFING
WHAT EXACTLY DID YOU DO IT OR
DID YOU NOT THE JURY CONVICTED
YOU. GET IT. SO WHAT IS IN THE
RECORD IT HAS BEEN TO ENSURE
JUSTICE. AND THAT THEY'LL BE
PROGRESSIVE. CONSEQUENCES
SHOULD SURE PROGRESSIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR CONTINUED
CRIMINALITY OR FOR MULTIPLE
OFFENSES THAT OCCUR. SO YOU
HAVE ORIGINAL ROBBERY. WELL ONE
OF THOSE DIDN'T COUNT. WHAT I
GONNA ENHANCE. WE'RE GONNA STOP
SENTENCE OH NO. JUST ONE. NO
I'M NOT GOING TO BUY THIS.
ARGUMENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
THERE IS AN OUTCRY RUSH IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IN
ANOTHER STAGE TO DESTROY THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. MAKE IT A FREE
FOR ALL WORLD. BOY I LOOK AT
TOSE BIG CITIES WHO HAVE
GOTTEN RID OF THEIR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. HAMPERED THEIR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS BUT AFTER
WORKING OUT WELL ISN'T IT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. DO YOU
NEED ANY GREATER TESTIMONY DID
YOU SET THE VICTIMS RATHER
THAN. CRIMINALS WERE GONNA.
BEING CRIMINALS BECAUSE OF THIS.
THIS GREAT RUSH THE DESTROYED
JUSTICE AND PUT HANDCUFFS. ON
ONE PORTION OF. WELL WE TAKE
THE HANDCUFFS OFF THE CRIMINALS
THE STATE NOW EIGHT THOUSAND
MORE. THE WORST OF THE WORST.
ARE GOING TO BE LET GO INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. DO YOU HAVE A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT AND
BECOME PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS. BUT
THEY WILL HAVE BEEN
REHABILITATED IN CUSTODY
SUFFICIENTLY NOT TO GO BACK. TO
THEIR OLD HABITS DIE HARD. A
GOOD PROGRESSION. CONSEQUENCES
OF WATER NEEDED YOU DO THAT
WITH YOUR OWN CHILDREN. IF THEY
KEEP DOING SOME THINGS THAT GET
DENIED SOME MORE PRIVILEGES.
IT'S LOGICAL IT'S HUMAN NATURE.
AND IT'S JUST AND THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS
BILL DIMINISHING JUSTICE.
ASSUMING THAT THIS OTHER
ACTIVITY THE CARD DID NOT
HAPPEN. SO WE'RE NOT GONNA
STACKED SENTENCES. OVER GOING
TO A SHOW THEY ALREADY SERVED
THEIR TIME. THIS IS ONE OF THE
WORST BILLS AND ALL OF THIS
ASSAULT. ON THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I URGE A NO
VOTE. AND AT LEAST KEEP THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO A DEGREE IN
THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE
VOTED FOR IT REPEATEDLY. THESE
ENHANCEMENTS. SENATOR FORGERS.
MR PRESIDENT IF I MAY I POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR ISSUE
LOOKS AT SINNERS CAN WERE YOU
ACCEPTED YES. WITH YOUR- THANK
YOU- WOULD YOU BE ABLETO HELP
ME BETTER UNDERSTAND OR
EXPLAIN. HOWTHE APPLICATION OF
THE ENHANCEMENT- PARTICULAR TO
ME THE- CIRCUMSTANCE FOR
DISMISSAL WOULD INCLUDE
APPLICATION THE ENHANCEMENT IF
IT WOULD RESULT IN A DISPARATE
RACIAL IMPACT. CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE. IS IT A
PROPORTIONAL. RACIAL IMPACT OR
IS A BY THE NUMBERS IT IS ALL
IT IS GUIDANCE TO THE- JUDGE
THE JUDGE DOES NOT HAVE TO USE-
HAVE SOME NUMBERS NEXT TO HIM
OR HER INDICATING WHEN THEY
HAVE OR HAVEN'T- ISSUE THE
ENHANCEMENT. OF BUT RATHER
WOULD THEY APPLY IT'S PURELY
GUIDANCE THAT IN THAT
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE YES.
THE DEFENDANTS WERE A- NO
MATTER- ANY RACE NO MATTER
WHICH RACE WOULD THEY APPLY
THIS ENHANCEMENT REGARDLESS SO
IN OTHER WORDS CAMPAIGN WHICH
THEY JUSTIFY IT FROM A OLOR
BLIND POINT OF VIEW AND IT IS
NOT. IN ANY WAY- ARE REQUIRED
THEM TO LOOK AT OKAY HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE I APPLIE THIS IN
THE PAST NO IT IS PURELY IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE WOULD I APPLY
THIS. IN A COLOR BLIND MANNER.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR BACKER. I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS MEASURE AND
I'LL SAY SOMETHING THAT I MAY
REPEAT IN IN SUBSEQUENT DEBATES
HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT WILL DEAL WITH
ENHANCEMENTS. AND WHEN YOU MAKE
A GENERAL STATEMENT WHICH IS.
TO CALL ATTENTION TO THE DATA
AND THE FACTS OF OUR SENTENCING.
I'LL SAY TO STATS IN PARTICULAR.
FIRSTLY THAT TEXAS KNOWN AS A
TOUGH ON CRIME STATE I THINK WE
ALL AGREE HAS TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES.
WE HAVE THIRTY TO FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE SERVING LIFE
SENTENCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MISSISSIPPI NOT ALSO KNOWN
PROGRESSIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STATE IS SECOND IN PROPORTION
OF LIFE SENTENCES IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM. THEY HAVE 10% OF THE
PRISONERS SERVING LIFE
SENTENCES WE HAVE 30% SERVING
LIFE SENTENCES. ENHANCEMENTS
ARE ONE OF THE REASONS WHY AND
I APPRECIATE THEOFFER TACKLING
THESE DIFFICULT- SUBJECTS. BUT
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF REFORMS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE A SPECIAL
REQUEST NIVEAU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE
CENTERS CAN OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH- MR
PRESIDENT SO CONTRARY TO IT ONE
FLOOR COMMENT S. B. EIGHTY ONE
DOES NOT ELIMINATE ANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
ENHANCEMENTS. AND ADDITIONALLY
NO PART OF S. B. EIGHTY ONE IS
RETROACTIVE THOSE CRRENTLY
SERVING TIME CANNOT CONDITION
TO BE RESENTENCED SP ONE EIGHTY
ONE CONTAINS NO PROVISION FOR
RESENTENCING IT ONLY APPLIES
GOING FORWARD. AND IT PROVIDES
JUDICIAL GUIDANCE IN THE
APPLICATION AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MA'AM SIR TERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS. I
BASE NO BECKER FIVE FOUR JUST
KNOW BRADFORD HI CABRERA.
CORTEZ THREE HI DALLY NO DODD
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERZBERG HI WAY SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOGUE. NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WINNER FIVE WELK. NO SOONER SHE
CAN REMOVE THE CALL. HI.
SANDERS CAN REMOVE THE CALL. NO
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FOLLOW HIM TO THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR RUBIO SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FIVE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING
TO STATE GOVERNMENTS. AND RUBIO
FOR GEORGE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT S. V. EIGHT OH FIVE
WHICH WILL CREATE A GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP THE NON PROFITS
SMALL PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATION STAY AFLOAT. THIS
BILL IS A LIFELINE TO SO MANY
OF THOSE SMALL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING DUE TO THE CLOSURE
OF THE PANDEMIC. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS RELY ON FUND
RAISING AND THEIR PERFORMANCES
AND THIS PAST YEAR THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO EITHER.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE
HEART OF SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND ALSO HELP THE
SURROUNDING BUSINESSES MAKE
ENDS MEET. SB EIGHT OH FIVE
WILL HELP THESE ORGANIZATIONS
AND ENSURE THAT THE ARTISTS ARE
TAKING CARE OF WITH PROPER
WAGES IMPROPER BENEFITS. S. B.
EIGHT OH FIVE IS ABOUT EQUITY
IT'S ABOUT JUSTICE IN ABOUT
AXIS IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE THE
ARTS. AS A PARLIAMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER I CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT THE PARTS ARE
DISAPPEARING EVERY DAY IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND THE ARTS CONTINUE
TO BE A STRONG PARTNER TO THESE
SCHOOLS THAT CANNOT PROVIDE FOR
EXPOSURE. AND I HAVE SEEN THESE
THEATER IN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
PARTNERSHIPS SUCH AS WRITING
CLASSES IF THEY PROVIDE FREE
TICKETS NOT ONLY FOR THE
STUDENTS BUT FOR THEIR PARENTS
SO THAT THEY CAN ALL ENJOY THE
ARTS AS A FAMILY. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO IN
COMPUTERS WERE THE VOICES CAN
BE HEARD. A LOT OF THESE
PERFORMERS DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW THEIR CRAFT
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
WEALTHY OR WELL CONNECTED TO
THE INDUSTRY SO THESE SMALL
NONPROFIT. ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDE THAT STEPPING STONE
THEY NEED. TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED AND FOLLOW THEIR DREAMS
I ALSO WANT TO REMIND US OF THE
ROLE THAT SMALL PERFORMING ARTS
HAVE PLAYED IN HISTORY. FROM
THE WOMEN'S SUFFRAGETTE
SUFFRAGE WHERE WOMEN ENGAGE
AFFLUENT. FEMALES FROM FROM
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES TO JOIN
THEIR CALLS. TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WHERE STRONG
IMAGERY PETER SPOKEN WORD. WAS
USED TO CONVEY THEIR MESSAGE.
TO THE AFTER CAMPESINO WHICH
WAS A SMALL THEATER THAT GREW
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO CONVEY
SOME OF THE INJUSTICES OF THE
FARM WORKER WERE EXPERIENCING.
AND HELPED ORGANIZE AND GET
BETTER WAGES AND SUPPORT. FOR
THE FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS.
CAN'T I ALSO WANT TO CONVEY
THAT THESE COMMUNITY THEATERS
WHEN THEY CLOSE THEY JUST DON'T
CLOSE BUT THE CLOTHES SO MANY
DREAMS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN THE
INNER CITY COMMUNITIES WHICH I
HAPPEN TO BE PART OF. WHEN I
WAS AYOUTH I GREW UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF GANGS DRUGS AND
VIOLENCE AND IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE ARTS UP CREATED. THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO EXPRESS
MYSELF IN A POSITIVE WAY. MY
LIFE MAY BE DIFFERENT TODAY.
AND LAST WEEK TO INCREDIBLE
PARTNERS JOINED THE COST TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WOULD
LIKE PERMISSION TO READ.
PERMISSION GRANTED THANK YOU
RENOWNED ACTOR AND ACTIVIST
DANNY GLOVER JOINS OUR COSTS
pTHIS BILL AND I QUOTE COMMUNITY
THEATERS IS ABOUT HEALING
COMMUNITY THEATER IS ABOUT
TRANSFORMATION COMMUNITY
THEATER IS ABOUT OUR STORY NOT
THEIR STORY THE WHOLE IDEA OF
ART IS A REFLECTION OF
OURSELVES THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO TRANSFORM
OURSELVES. THROUGH ART AND WE
DO IT EVERY SINGLE DAY. AWARD
WINNER ACTOR EDWARD JAMES OLMOS
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT SAID I
HAD TO LEARN MY CRAFT AND LEARN
THROUGH FOURTEEN STRONG YEARS
OF THEATER BEFORE I STEPPED
ONTO A STAGE TO DO AND PART TWO
BY TWO POINT AND SUIT SUIT.
ARTS ARE THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT FOR STRENGTH
TO CULTURE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND PETER THE NUMBER ONE GOAL
IF IT WAS NOT FOR SMALL
THEATERS IN THIS CITY I WOULD
NOT BE STANDING HERE AS EDWARD
JAMES OLMOS THE ARTIST.
NONPROFIT SMALL THEATERS ARE
THE KEY TO THE EXISTENCE OF
ACTING. AND OUR ART FORM THAT'S
WHERE IT ALL BEGINS SOME
MEMBERS I WANT TO ASK THAT WE
DON'T GO BACK TO A TIME WHERE
THE ARTS WAS ONLY FOR THE
AFFLUENT. THE WELL T. LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OUR INNER
CITY COMMUNITIES ALSO GET TO
EXPERIENCE. WHAT IS THE ARTS
TODAY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
WANNA STAND AND THE- BANK AND
ENCOURAGE. MY COLLEAGUES TO THE
AUTHOR- TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS I AM A VERY VERY STRONG
AND PROACTIVE SUPPORTER OF
SMALL PERFORMING THEATERS OF
THE ARTS. ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. UP FOR
OUR YOUTH OF WHETHER IT WAS-
THE KOREAN MUSEUM WHERE THERE
IT WAS- PASAL ONE A ONE IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS. LATINO THEATER
DOWNTOWN LA- THE SHAKESPEAREAN
THEATRE IN MY DISTRICT THESE
ARE ALL FORMS I THINK OF VERY
VERY POWERFUL VERY IMPORTANT-
THEATERS FOR OUR- OUR
COMMUNITIES. SO I RISE TO
SUPPORT AND I ENCOURAGE AND
SUPPORT THE AUTHOR TO PLEASE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. THE LABOR
ISSUES- THERE'S NO REASON THAT
WE CAN HAVE BOTH AND I KNOW
SHE'S WORKING HARD ON IT SO I
RISE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN CHINO AND REVIEW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WHAT
WANNA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ADVICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM TWO THREE SIX. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST. I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED.
HI LISA I LIVE MY OWN. MCGUIRE
HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. OCHO A VOGUE I CAN HI
FORTUNE TINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. HI AMBERG I
LIKE CASKEY I WINNER I WELK NO.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM ONE SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT I DON'T HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING- WINNER THE FLOOR'S
YOURS I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT- THIS BILL IS A
VERY TECHNICAL BELL- BUT IT IS
A BILL THAT ENSURES THAT WHEN A
CITY HAS LOCALLY ZONE FOR SMALL
MULTI UNIT. MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING BETWEEN THREE AND TEN
YEAR NOTES THAT THAT HOUSING
CAN ACTUALLY GET BUILT ON
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL ADDRESSES
SITUATIONS- WHERE CITY HAS
LOCALLY ZONE FOR THREE TO TEN
UNITS- BUT THAT HAS A VERY
RESTRICTED SQUARE FOOTAGE OF
LIMITATIONS- THAT MAKE IT
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY BUILD WHAT THE CITY
HAS OWNED FOR IN OTHER WORDS
THE CITY HAS GIVEN WITH ONE
HAND. AND TAKEN WITH THE OTHER-
WE MIGHT WANT TO CALL THIS
GHOST ZONING OR- NOT ZONING
THAT IS NOT ENTIRELY HONEST AND
SO WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS
ENSURE THAT WHEN A CITY HAS
OWNED LOCALLY- FOR SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN THREE AND TEN YEAR
NOTES- DIED THERE ARE SQUARE
FOOTAGE LIMITS IN PLACE THAT
ACTUALLY ALLOW SOMEONE. TO
PHYSICALLY BE ABLE TO BUILD-
THOSE- THAT- HOUSING WE KNOW
THAT THIS MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
HOUSING FUTURE. THE BILL ALSO
ENSURES THAT IF YOU HAVE A PRE
EXISTING PARCEL THAT DOESN'T
COMPLY WITH OUR CURRENT-
MINIMUM LOT SIZE REQUIREMENTS
THAT YOU CAN STILL BUILD
HOUSING ON THOSE ARE
GRANDFATHERED PARCELS FOR
CALLING THIS IS A GOOD HOUSING
GO I WANNA. THANK YOU- THE
CENTER FOR HEALDSBURG FOR
WORKING WITH US ON IT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ERNESTINE MEN OR THIRTY
CALL OR- ON AS- FOR SEVEN
EIGHT. YOU KNOW YOU'RE TAKING.
ALAN BY ARCHULETA. AT KINS.
BASED BACKER. FIVE FOUR JUST.
BRADFORD HI HAVE A- I CORTESE.
HI DALLY I DON. FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG
FIVE WAY SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES. FIVE CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN. NIELSEN I ASSURE VOGUE.
NO PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO. ROSS
FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN.
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NO THE CARD
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA AT KINS. BAIT NO. FOR
JUST. LIMO ON. MELINDA'S NEWMAN.
POURTANT TINO NO. STERN. GROVE
I TO KNOW. ARE YOU TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS FAR THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FILE. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
MEMBERS IF OFF FLORIDA SHOULD
RETURN GONNA LOOK CALLS. OUR
MEMBERS WERE LOOKING CALL ON
FILE EITHER ONE FORTY ONE ONE
FORTY S. B. TWO SIX TWO I'M
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. FORTUS NO. EGGMAN I-
TADO. LIVE MON HI. FIVE THIRTY
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MOVING ON THE FALL THIRTY
NINE S. B. EIGHTY ONE BY
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RETURN THE- CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. CABRERO GLAZER. HER
TADO. THE MON I MELINDA'S NO
NEWMAN I AMBERG. MARCH TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM TWO THREE SIX S.
B. ETAL FIVE MOUNT SECTOR
PLEASE LOOK CALL. ATKINS I.
DALLY. RAMON I MELINDA'S. I
NIELSEN. PLEASE CALL THE HELP
THE MEMBERS. DALLY. NIELSEN.
BORDERS FOR BURGERS BORJA CITED
NO. PORGES I DON'T KNOW. MA'AM
SECTOR WITH ANOTHER MEMBER.
SIDEROAD DROBO CORPORATE
PURPOSE BUT YOUR BOAT I TOO AM
A TELEPHOTO ALL RIGHT TO KNOW.
NIELSEN NO. ALL RIGHT R. THIRTY
FOUR KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THAT WERE
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE BUT SENATOR BACKER MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR BACKER AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. SENATOR
BOOKER. FURTHER EASES THE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO
PURCHASING NEW AT AN ELECTRIC
AND HYBRID VEHICLES FOR LOWER
INCOME CONSUMERS PARTICIPATING
UNDER THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM THIS SHOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED ANYONE THAT WE ARE
NOT ON TRACK ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
MEET OUR GOALS FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND THIS IS A
PROACTIVE STEP TO HELPING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AT TRADE
OUT SWAP OUT HIGHLY POLLUTING
CARS FOR USED ELECTRIC VEHICLES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE
IN CHINO AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS BY BASE NO
BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A DAUGHTER
HI CORTEZ HE. DALLY NO DODD I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATE MY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES. NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LISA HI THE MON I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN I NELSON. NO A SHOW
VOGUE. PAN HI FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS. FIVE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
SKINNER I TURN HI NUMBER FIVE
BY ASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI.
M. SIX THREE PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. CORTESE. GROVE. FIVE
MELINDA'S. OCHO ABODE I. MARCH
THIRTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA CALL.
PRICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS THAT'S
OUR FINAL ITEM FOR TWO DAYS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THEIR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS
TIME. CENTER COPYRIGHT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT BUDGET SUB FOR
COMMITTEE ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND GENERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL MEET AT ONE
THIRTY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. BUDGET SO FOR WILL MEET
AT ONE THIRTY AM ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NEXT UP SENATOR ADMIT.
BUDGET SUB THREE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WILL MEET AT ONE
THIRTY IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS.
BUT IT'S UP THREE WILL MEET
HERE IN SENATE CHAMBERS AT ONE
THIRTY. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER I CONSIDER THIS
A LITTLE. I'M SORRY. MEMBERS AT
THE REQUEST OF THE SENATOR FROM
SAN JOSE CENTER CORTESE WE
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THE NINE VICTIMS
WHO DIED THIS MORNING AFTER A
HORRIFIC SHOOTING THE DECLINE
TOOK PLACE AT THE VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
RAILYARD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OUR
THOUGHTS AND SYMPATHIES ARE
WITH THE VICTIMS THEIR FAMILIES
AND WITH THE PEOPLE OF SAN
JOSE. AND ALL OF SILICON VALLEY.
NOW MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO ANY
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS
THE JUSTICE CLLR ARTISTRY
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE AND HARD WORK
TODAY. MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
FOR- ETHNOLOGY ING IN THAT
MOMENT OF SILENCE AT THE
REQUEST OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN JOSE. AND WITH THAT OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT
NINE AM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY. AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE'LL RECONVENE FRIDAY
AT NINE AM.